So Leute, da bin ich, bald ist Schicht im Schacht, wir spielen noch ein paar Runden
Battlefield 2042.
Ich hab mir überlegt, ob wir heute Abend lieber ein paar Geräte flashen, aber Geräte
flashen machen wir dann morgen oder am Montag.
Wir spielen jetzt noch ein paar Runden, weil morgen früh, 9 Uhr, ist überhaupt das
Stream schon richtig on, Säck, Säckplitz.
Ja, ja, Stream ist on, Moin Leute, also, äh, was wollte ich sagen, wo bin ich gerade stehengeblieben?
Genau, also wir spielen jetzt noch ein paar Runden Battlefield, China-Chinesen-Geräte
flashen machen wir dann, die Tage, weil morgen 9 Uhr ist Schluss.
Morgen 9 Uhr ist die Beta vorbei und ich hab mir gedacht, ich nehm jetzt noch ein bisschen,
was?
Ach fuck, ich kann nicht aufnehmen, mein Shadowplay ist ja kaputt, ah ne, es geht wieder, ok.
Lull, warum ging das gestern nicht?
Man weiß es nicht, man weiß es nicht, aber ich mach mal ein Shadowplay mal an, mein Reverse
Recording Shadowplay, damit ich ein paar gescheite Sachen aufnehmen kann, dass ich noch so für
die nächste Woche vielleicht ein bisschen Gameplay hab, wenn ich auf YouTube was hoch lade, gar
nicht mal um mich so sehr, jetzt weiter mit Battlefield, morgen, bis morgen 9 Uhr, geht
die Beta, dann ist vorbei.
Das ist Battlefield 1942 Menümusik, ja leider nicht Battlefield 2042 Menümusik, das hat
ja keine Menümusik und das was es hat ist halt, so wie das andere auch, ich weiß gar
nicht, was mit denen los ist, warum die seit Bad Company 2 keinen gescheiten Soundtrack
mehr haben.
Wie viel Geld kam eigentlich mit den Subs beim Tierheim zusammen, das kann ich dir zeigen.
Exquisite, Witter, ich hab ans Tierheim überwiesen 200 Euro, allerdings muss ich dazu sagen,
die 200 Euro, das waren nicht alles Subs, weil mit Subs wären es glaub ich bloß 100-120
Euro oder so gewesen, warte mal, wir hatten 30 Subs ungefähr, 30 Subs mal 2 Euro, guck
mal, noch nix, 60 Euro, ich hab aufgerundet, ich hab es noch mal ungefähr verdoppelt,
was ans Subs reingekommen ist, ich hoffe es ist ein gutes Tierheim, es ist nicht nur
ein Tierheim, ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, aber ich verfolge dir oft Wetter schon ne
Weile und das sieht so aus, als machen die gute Sachen, ich hab denen schon öfters was
gespendet.
Und letztens hab ich ja so viele Subs gekriegt, als ich gesagt hab, jeder Subs ab, wann war
denn das, keine Ahnung, 20 Uhr geht ans Tierheim, es waren 30 Subs, dem als Problem nur 60
Euro und das was natürlich nicht so sinnvoll ist, der Rest geht ja zu Besos, ich hab mich
gedacht, komm wir runden das jetzt einfach mal auf auf 200 Euro, aber die brauchen das
ohne Scheiß, also aktuell, gerade in der aktuellen Zeit, übrigens meine Katze steht total irgendwie
mein Hemd, gerade in der Zeit, wo jetzt die Leute festgestellt haben, oh fuck Corona und
sie können doch kein Haustier mehr haben und geben das dann zurück und so war es wirklich
kacke.
Übrigens, wer es noch nicht gesehen hat, mein Chef hat mich gestern angeschrieben, gestern,
vorgestern, heute ist Samstag, ne, lustig, aber mein Chef hat mich angeschrieben vorgestern
und meinte so, hey, Zeiterfassung, du bist noch 72 Stunden im Minus, okay und direkt danach
hat er mich gefragt, was hältst du vor der Battlefield Beta, das war was, da sieht man
mal, mittlerweile sind Chefs nicht irgendwie mehr 60-jährige Boomer, sondern ganz normale
Leute wie du und ich, gut, ich mein ich bin auch 37, das ist es halt so, aber das fand
ich, das fand ich schon witzig, aber hier, warum hat das 416 Likes, Likes, Wub Arrive,
unarrived ma, unarrived ma, Wub, Wub Arrive, Bastion, alter Bastion, ja, gleich gehts los,
egal, der dürfte glaube ich ziemlich genauso alt sein wie ich, ich tippe drauf, der ist
vielleicht 1-2 Jahre älter, weiß nicht, ob ich das jetzt hier erzählen darf im Stream,
aber mein Chef hat sogar übelste Cosplay, Weep-Cosplay-Dinger früher gemacht, mit Perücke
und Zeug, ich glaube der ist 1-2 Jahre älter oder zumindest hat er früher auch viel Battlefield
gespielt, so wir legen gleich los, was schauen, was mich ja übrigens sehr erheitert hat Leute,
das wüsste ich euch jetzt zwar zeigen, was mich ja sehr erheitert hat sind wieder die
Comments, übrigens richtig Poggers, die letzten Videos kommen richtig gut an, was mich ja
wieder sehr erheitert hat unter den Comments vom Video sind, oh fuck, hoffentlich finde
ich das jetzt, es gab wieder Leute, also die meisten haben es ja verstanden, hat dein Chef
unter dem Video, nee ich glaube nicht, also die meisten haben es ja verstanden wie ich
das meine, ja, mir geht es ja hauptsächlich darum, dass ich selbst mir wünsche, dass das
Game gut wird, aber es hat viele Sachen gerade gibt, die mich daran zweifeln lassen, dein
Vater arbeitet in einer Zellenfirma wie ich, ok, ja das ist durchaus möglich, so und die
meisten haben es verstanden, die meisten haben verstanden wie gesagt, dass ich mir selbst
wünsche, dass das Game gut wird und dass ich halt so meine Zweifel habe, aber du hattest
auch wieder Leute dabei, da ist mir das Gehirn geschmolzen, als ich die Comments gelesen
habe, ja, wo ist es denn hier, ich kritisiere fast überhaupt keine Visuals, ich kritisiere,
dass man Leute nicht erkennt, ja, aber ich habe glaube ich nicht eine Sache zur Grafik
gesagt, so, so, dann hat er das Spiel wahrscheinlich nicht gespielt, dann hat er das Spiel wahrscheinlich
nicht gespielt, das ist blöd, die Leute reden sich das immer schön, warum reden sich das
die Leute immer so schön, ja, natürlich muss er auf der einzigen Sache rumreiten, die ich
erzählt habe, die nicht stimmt, das ist schon klar, das ist das einzige, das ist mir danach
aufgefallen, dass es ein Turm ist und kein Hund den der hat, aber weide Güte, anscheinend
mehr gab es nicht, ne, aber wo ist denn der Typ hier, ich hatte hier vor ein paar Minuten
als ich reingeguckt habe, da habe ich schon wieder einen gesehen, der gesagt, Max, du
flames schon wieder so viel über das Spiel, die haben doch gesagt, dass sind die Probleme
bekannt und so, wisst ihr, das ist eine Sache, die irritiert mich seit ich Gameplay-Videos
mache, für COD-Spieler ist Battlefield voll das komische Spiel, warum, gibt es wirklich
eine Kategorie Spieler, die sich COD-Spieler nennt, oder wer sagt Gott-Spieler, oder gibt
es wirklich eine, die sich Battlefield spielt, das ist doch blödsinn, mal realistisch betrachtet,
so in den Mechanics, die Unterschied zwischen Call of Duty und Battlefield, die sind verschwindend
gering, also ich weiß gar nicht, das verwirrt mich seit Anfang an, dass die Leute sagen,
ah, ich bin voll Blood Call of Duty-Spieler, ob ich in Battlefield klarkomme, ich weiß
es nicht, oder umgedreht, natürlich, warum soll man da nicht klarkommen, das ist eine
Sache von 1-2 Tagen Eingewöhnen, alter wo ist denn jetzt der Typ, da ist richtig mein
Gehirn, mein Gehirn geschmolzen, als ich das Comment gelesen habe, das Comment von dem
Bestand nur, achja, das ist geil, what, Bugfield 2042, Call of Bugs, Halo muss das Jahr retten,
wenigstens nur Far Cry 6, super, von den 8 Maps hat DICE entschieden, diese Maps ist
das beste für eine Beta, wir wohnen Ge-Eat, hä, was, ich hab 20 Eco-Punkte verloren nur
beim Lesen, alter, und die sind auch geil, die immer sagen, du heulst so viel rum, guck
hier, zum Beispiel, ich muss nur noch heulen, nur wieder jemand am rumjammern, hör auf
rumzumachen, das sind alles Sachen, die wusste man seit Release, das ist so, das sind so
ultra 3-Hat-Comments, ich mein, erstens das Spiel ist nicht mal Release, das müsste ihm
eigentlich klar sein, er meint wahrscheinlich Beta Release, aber ehrlich gesagt, das Comment
ist total in sich unschlüssig, das macht es ja sogar noch schlimmer, das macht es
ja sogar noch schlimmer, wenn aber man das alles weiß, und es ist alles bekannt, und
es ist trotzdem kacke, oh man, da sind wieder Spezialisten dabei gewesen, hä, äh, ja,
ok, wir starten mal das Spiel, start das verdammte Spiel, auf gehts, du, du, du, du,
heute läuft die noch, ja, die Beta läuft bis morgen um 9 Uhr, C-E-S-T, also Central
European Summertime, also, das was wir haben, wenn du noch Spieler brauchst, äh, ja, ich
will erst mal gucken, wo die sind, die ich gestern geadded hab, ähm, du hast mich glaub
ich auch geadded, ne, du hast mich, warte mal, der Name kommt mir bekannt, hast du mich
nicht auch geadded gestern, da ist er doch, ah ja, auf gehts, bashen, alter, bashen, ah,
ich muss umschalten auf Gameplay Capture, Sekunde, Sekunde, ne, ne, ne, mitspielen
geht erst ab Diamant Subscription, ne, ne, ich spiel jetzt erst mal so ein paar Runden,
ähm, Moment, Moment, ich muss umschalten Game Capture, sonst buggt es rum, so, excellent,
excellent, so, wir müssen bisschen lauter machen, sonst hört man wieder nix, und den
Soundtrack müssen wir auch mal aufmachen, bam, voraus, auf gehts, äh, Dr. Evil guck
ich in weit, jetzt ansonsten in weit, erst mal noch keinen, es sei denn die von gestern
kommen wieder, ähm, ich spiel jetzt erst mal so, ich versuch mal ein bisschen was zu
Capturen, so, ist halt drin, jo, dauert noch kurz, geht erst ab zum Portal schon, das hab
ich noch gar nicht ausprobiert, was passiert, wenn man da draufklickt, ah, ne, currently
not available, null, aha, aha, aha, daran erkenne ich eine Sache, das ist nicht exakt
das gleiche Bild, was wir im Preview gespielt haben, weil in meinem Preview Bild konnte ich
das hier anklicken, und da kam so, so, so, so, so ein Reload von dem Menü, das ist nicht
exakt das gleiche, so, so, deswegen hatte ich auch so viele, äh, Wettereffekte, und
jetzt nicht, das war nicht exakt das gleiche, die haben bestimmt die Server-Settings ein
bisschen hoch gedreht für dieses Anspiel-Event, weil die sich gedacht haben, hey, wir wollen
unsere geilen Wettereffekte zeigen, und ich hab, ich war der einzige, es gab nen Discord,
es gab nen Discord für, für die, für diese Pre, äh, Preview-Events, gab's von EA in
Discord, ich war der Einzige im Chat, der, äh, irgendwas reingeschrieben hat, was mich
nervt, ich bin mir immer nicht sicher, ob ich das machen soll, nicht, dass die mich
dann instant wieder ausladen, aber auf der anderen Seite, damit müssen sie klarkommen,
das machts game im Endeffekt da besser, sie beten nur für Vorbesteller, nein, seit gestern
ist die, ist die open für alle, so, wir testen, wir testen heute mal ein bisschen was rum,
also wir haben ja gestern, wir spielen, wobei, wir spielen uns erstmal kurz ein, wir spielen
uns erstmal mit der OP, mit der OP-Geschichte ein, ähm, ich probier mal die anderen Specialists
heute ein bisschen aus, das ist halt hier, das ist halt hier der OP, OP-S-Fuck-Kombi,
die ich hier am Start hab, ähm, ach ja, ist eigentlich, geht eigentlich 1080p, gescheit,
1080p, 7, ähm, 7 Mbit, Vehikel voll, nix ist hier voll, okay, Keg-Wade, Alter, Hull,
ich glaub, es geht los, Hull in 20-21, so, zack, zack, zack, zack, excellent, auf gehts,
was ist eigentlich hier der Unterschied zwischen den Munis, nochmal, sag mal, ist heute lauter
als gestern, bin ich dumm oder, ist es lauter als gestern oder ist es exakt genauso, sagt
mal, mir kommt es lauter vor, vielleicht ist mein Ohr heute auch empfindlicher, warum auch
immer, ist genauso, okay, so, was ist denn hier nochmal der Unterschied dazwischen gewesen,
also, das hier ist die normale, Clear-Side-Picture-Vertikel-Recoil-Control, bla bla bla, Firepower hat man hier mehr
und hier hat man, ah, das hier ist quasi, das hier ist quasi so die, die Close-Quarter-Munition,
nee, das ist Close, das ist Close Combat, Close Combat hat man hier, okay, alles klar,
verstehe, YOLO, ah, wir haben schon gecaptchert, rauf gehts, ey, der Range von diesem Hook,
das macht mich immer noch fertig, Beta ist nur für Vorbestellern, nein, achso, hab ich
gerade schon gelesen, nee, kann jeder spielen aktuell, aber, wenn du spielen willst, musst
du dich beeilen, denn die Beta läuft noch bis morgen neun Uhr, bitte dir auch, dass
so der Ambience-Sound einfach irgendwie nicht da ist, wenn du, ich mein, es muss nicht
jede Map so sein, wie du spornst in Metro rein, wenn du in Metro rein spornst, dann
ist im Prinzip, sobald du spawnen drückst, shake dein Screen vor Explosionen, das muss
ja auch nicht unbedingt sein, es muss ja nicht total übertreiben, ich seh grad, bekannter
von mir, castet grad Solo-Valorant-Matches, den entweder hoste ich die nachher, oder wir
gehen gleich mal kurz ins Stream rein und spammen einmal alle Wupp-Pock, oh, Dependsman
ist am Start, wir spammen alle einmal Wupp-Pock und dann spielen wir weiter Battlefield, war
hier unten grad was, oh, keck, soll erstmal einspielen, du lässt du mich in Ruhe Panzer,
du triffst mich, du eh nicht, schrägt, schön AD-AD-Spam, AD-AD-Spam, oder jetzt trifft
er mich nicht, easy, easy, easy, da hinten ist er, oh, ich wurd geheilt, Poggers für
Teamplay in Chat, ich wurd geheilt, ich glaub das ist das erste Mal seit der Beta, ernsthaft,
aha, aha, funktioniert wieder nicht, dass ich geheilt wurde, Poggers, Alter, ich will
hier hoch, please, please, lass mich rauf, C'mon, oh, schnell weg, schnell weg, und hier
unten ist einer, Cookie, ich retz dich, schnell, schnell, pass mal auf, pass mal auf, wie lang
das Gerät so dauert, ich sterb jetzt eh, ne, war ich nicht, in den Kopf, ok, ich muss
sagen, die letzten zwei Tage Intensivstunden-Kreinden hat sich hier gelohnt, ich treff wieder halbwegs
was, nicht so mega ppeger wie am Anfang, ok, das war jetzt natürlich mit Ansage, vorbei
geschossen mit Ansage, vermisst du die normalen Klassen, ok, die normalen Klassen sind ja
noch da, das Problem ist nur, dass jeder jetzt einen Specialist hat, plus, also, guck
mal, die normalen Klassen sind ja da, genauso wie vorher, das sind die normalen Klassen,
das Problem ist jetzt nur, dadurch, dass die Waffen free for all sind und noch OP Sachen
wie Crapling Hooks dabei kommen, dass es eigentlich kaum noch ne Rolle spielt, dass es das gibt,
das ist das eigentliche Problem, wisst ihr, wie ich mein, die Klassen sind da, ich, ich
hab keine Ahnung, wo der Dude ist, ich dachte es ist ein Feind, easy, by the way, mega OP,
OP AF, der Crapling Hook, seht ihr das, ich meine ernsthaft, du hast, du hast die beste
Pose aller Zeiten, das war jetzt dumm, oh Gott, jetzt, jetzt ist es natürlich leer, jetzt
ist es natürlich leer, muss sein, ich glaube, Chats hat sich gehofft, oh, hab ich gerätzt,
nein, nein, wer ist jetzt auch gewesen, ja, genau, Chat meint, er hofft, dass die Server
zum Release hinkriegen, ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen problematisch, aus zwei Gründen,
das ist auch so ein Punkt, den glaube ich einige nicht nachvollziehen können, ich persönlich
vermute mal, dass die Server Seite und die client Seite gar nicht mal so viel miteinander
zu tun haben, also das, was wir hier auf dem client haben, mit den ganzen Bugs, mit den
ganzen Glitches, sollte eigentlich auf Server Seite besser laufen, es wäre sehr merkwürdig,
wenn die Server Seite, ich quasi jetzt auch eine Monate alte Version laufen lassen müssten,
das wäre komisch, ich würde eigentlich eher vermuten, die Server Seite, die ist relativ,
ja, aktuell, aber halt das andere nicht, was wir spielen und dementsprechend, oh, oh,
oh, das war dumm, oh, war das pepega, Alter, ich hab nicht gecheckt, ich hab schon am Grappling
gehockt, geswitcht hab, Alter, kriegst die 3 Head, da hast du wieder IQ minus, Minus gemacht,
oh man, lull, ich muss mal richtig ausgreifen hier, wo ist er, komm her, wenn ich spotten
könnte, ey, wie viel, please, wie viel hältst du aus, wie viel hältst du aus, mal gucken,
mal gucken, mal gucken, ob ich den treffe, ok, easy, wir gehen jetzt runter, runter,
wir werden jetzt gebashed, Alter, bashen, bashen, bashen, hallo, hallo, please, ach,
er ist downed, ach, das ist so blöd gemacht, dass man downed Leute, downed Leute sehen aus,
wie Leute, die krabbeln, WTF, das sind doch Bots, äh, bin ich mir jetzt nicht so sicher,
waren das Bots, habt ihr das im Kill gesehen, nee, ich glaub, das war kein Bot, ich glaub,
das war einfach einer der Brain-Arf-Cover, welche Einschülle, alles low, alles low,
alles low, alles low, oh, wir kriegen ein bisschen auf den Sack gerade, ach, was ist denn los
eigentlich, vielleicht muss ich erstmal ein bisschen warm werden, keine Ahnung, oder sind
jetzt bloß noch die guten Leute übrig, was, war der Gegner tot, war das irgendwie ghosting,
oder was war das, das ging einfach straight durch, red dot ohne dot, naja, egal, vielleicht
muss ich erstmal ein bisschen warm werden, ich mein, wir können nicht so, wir können
nicht so hard bashen jedes Mal, wie gestern die paar Runden, monkaS, alter, was geht denn
heute, nein, der Bullet-Trop ist nicht so krass, die Hit-Rack ist im Arsch, der Bullet-Trop
ist nicht das Problem, wo gehen wir jetzt hin, hier, so, die stellsten bestimmt, pass
auf, pass auf hier Leute, hier kommen gleich welche raus, oh, oh, das ist eine schlechte
Idee, der Tunnel ist meistens instant death, alles klar, müssen wir aufpassen, alter, sag
mal, heute, heute ist ja nix mehr hier, heute ist ja instant death, guck mal hier, 8-6,
Keg-Wade, alter, pass auf, ich sag euch, jetzt kickt SPMM, letzten zwei Tage, gerekt, as
und jetzt, und jetzt, jebaited, jetzt haben sie erst SPMM eingeschaltet, jetzt vorbei,
mit Spaß, da unten kann ich nicht rein, ist zu viel, ich muss ein bisschen ein Pad rumschieben,
so vielleicht, irgendwie komm ich heute nicht klar, so, geht nix, komm wir gehen jetzt
zur Rakete, auf geht's, sind alle Level 3 und 4, was bin ich denn für eins, hat es
irgendjemand beobachtet, hat Danny gerade two-shotted, Siri, ja, come on, wirklich,
links ist er, jetzt aber, ok, by the way, Munition wechseln, instant Munition refill,
poggers, was auch immer man sich dabei gedacht hat, ich weiß es nicht, ich weiß, und ich
kenne die Granaten, denkst, Flugbahn nicht wirklich, SPMM gleich schwitzen, ja, alter,
da guckt ihr, das ist ja, das ist ja der Head-Clitch-Abfuck-Extrem, guckt euch das mal an, und aus irgendwelchen
Gründen hättet ihr es auch nicht, ok, vielleicht müssen wir jetzt wirklich den da drauf machen,
wo ist er, mach deinen Scheiß-Kopf raus, jawoll, ok, jetzt Raketen-Stells, auf geht's, easy,
wir brauchen, wir müssen irgendwie erstmal auf unsere Stats kommen, sonst muss ich hier
aninstallen, lass mich in Ruhe, nein, soll ich mich in Ruhe lassen, kann man nicht rüber,
oder aber es könnte sein, dass wir dominate Gegner, oh, wir haben heftige Gegner, ok,
wir müssen das anders machen, oder so von der Seite, wait a minute, warum genau spawn ich,
ah, ich bin in der Luft gespawnt, weil der Typ in der Luft gespawnt ist, das ist natürlich
schon ein bisschen doof, dass man das überhaupt kann, komm, wir versuchen es mal, die Zip-Line
hab ich noch nie benutzt, der basht uns eh hier weg, da ist bestimmt einer, moin, hab
ich grad ernsthaft eingespawtet, hä, hallo, nope, ist nix, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
hier ist nix, 720, ich wusste es gar nicht, dass ich einen Achieve hab, doch, ich hab
einen Achieve, so, Auto, gut, jetzt wäre natürlich ne Anzeige cool, im Auto, was wir, was wir
bräuchten, ich weiß, ich kann mir nämlich beim besten Willen nicht merken, wo hier was
ist, easy, den fahren wir jetzt um, ok, den fahren wir nicht um, man, du sollst dich nicht
da hoch hucken, die machen Battle Royale Maps ohne, dass die kleiner werden, ja anscheinend,
der sollte sich an die Seite hucken, what, was ist mit dem los, oh, pass auf, Five-Fat-Play,
Five-Fat-Play, Five-Fat-Play so easy, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
Weifelplay, so easy.
By the way, hier im Busch ist irgendeiner, man sieht aber nix.
Die Dudes! Die Dudes! Lul!
Okay, unsere Stats stimmen wieder, alles gut.
Alles gut. Wie viel FPS hast du? Warte mal.
Perf, Overlay... Moment.
Perf, Perf, Overlay, Draw, FPS, eins, zack.
Kannste gucken, wie viel FPS ich hab.
Und vielleicht bist du der Erste auf dieser Welt, der versteht, was das bedeutet, was da oben steht.
Nice, Hack.
Guck hier, ich hol dich, ich rennst dich.
Pass mal auf, vielleicht krieg ich den.
Komm, bewegen, move, move, move, move.
Nice. Und jetzt wieder zurück ins Auto.
Okay, fahren wir denen mal ein bisschen entgegen.
Gucken wir mal, Bash hoch.
Boah, die Steuerung, meine Güte.
Hat jemand die letzte Halo-Mission gespielt, Halo 3? So ungefähr ist das.
Was hiervon ist denn jetzt Gegner noch? C?
Spawn Rape, auf geht's.
Easy.
Ich hab eine 1008-Sti. Meine Güte, Lul.
Please, lass mich einfach mal rausfahren.
Nope, es ist denied, geradeaus gefahren wird hier nicht.
Na, weg.
Geradeaus gefahren wird nicht.
Du musst beim Lenken Shift loslassen und dann wird's dann besser.
Vielleicht läuft flüssig, weil Max den Clean-PC hat.
Also, das läuft bei mir auch nicht so flüssig.
Das läuft ganz okay, aber ich würde nicht sagen, dass das irgendwie mega flüssig ist oder so.
Also, es ist definitiv weit von 144 oder 120 Hertz entfernt.
Ich tippe mal irgendwie so auf, keine Ahnung, 60.
Oder so vielleicht. Was auch immer diese Werte da oben heißen, das checkt ja eh keiner.
Oder checkt die Werte da oben jemand?
Nvidia Overlay? Bei mir geht das Nvidia Overlay nicht.
Da steht er. Origin Overlay.
Was war das? F1? Einstellung?
Und jetzt?
FPS-Zähler anzeigen. Ah, oben links.
Vorgass. Seht ihr das jetzt auch?
Seht ihr auch oben? Oh, ich werde gerätzt. Nein!
Okay, ich bin nicht so gut.
Alter, wo? Was ist hier gerade passiert?
Das hat ja nur sich hoch und runter bewegt gerade.
Seht ihr das oben links? Die FPS-Anzeige? Oder ist das ein Overlay, was nicht?
Hast du überhaupt Geforce Experience? Ja.
Okay.
Was ist denn hier los? Okay, Achtung.
3-Head-Time.
Vorgass, Vorgass, Vorgass.
Deswegen... das ist halt so krass, der Hog-Typ.
Okay, natürlich nicht, wenn du ein komplettes Gegner-Team hast, was dich ubeymt.
Aber, cpu, ich habe eine 8700k.
700k
Matches sind aber echt schwerer als gestern das ist vielleicht vielleicht doch sbmm angesagt
Nein, ich glaube es nicht gerade nicht in der beta
Oh, was ist das da achte ok ok hier ist was ich habe aber kein Plastenschimmer wo hier ist so hier ist so viel
meine güte alter ich muss weg also heute bist du wirklich geäymt von allen aber wirklich von allen
stellen mann ok wie kriegen wir wie kriegen wir das hier hin chat sagt es macht spaß aber was
mich der wischer ist ist das gegner spotten ja man kann überhaupt nicht spotten spotten
ist ja spot ja ist ja gut was alter was ist denn heute mit den gegnern los mann du bist
ja heute instan direkt und ich war wahrscheinlich vorher auch schon hittet hat man eigentlich
eine ping anzeige nicht scheide hat man irgendwie eine ping anzeige nicht irgendwas ach hier oben
14 millisekunden 14 millisekunden da wo man auberlei drüber ist ok die gegner sind opa f
die auern uns richtig hart dafür dafür geht's ultra range das ding auch nicht wir müssen
übrigens immer noch versuchen ein zu zu captain hooken stehen die stehen die server in frankfurt
das ist aws server ich vermute mal dass die mehrfach schlicht und ergreifend vorhanden
sind also halt je nach region und es kann durchaus sein dass die in frankfurt in frankfurt oder
köln würde ich jetzt mal vermuten so oder auch wieder ein punkt nix los oder clusterfuck
gerade sind wir bei nix los das gar nicht so genau wo ich hin soll wenn ich ehrlich bin
er müsste ja schon in die base hier runter müsste ja schon irgendwie in die base hier
runter schön durch den boden klitschen ok man kann es ja mal probieren man kann es ja
mal probieren hier ist doch einer ich sehe den ich ich sehe nichts in diesem spiel man
ist doch ein witz oder das ist doch echt ein witz die gegner visibility ich mein ernsthaft
wer hat den gesehen wer hat den legit gesehene ich weiß der chat sagt jetzt obviously natürlich
easy visible von oben kommt was what the hell ist heute mit den gegnern los mensch also
das ist ja mal absolut nicht zu vergleichen mit gestern heute sitzen die ja komplett quasi
im nicht hinter im arsch sitzen die die gegner heute die haben gestern den ganzen tag geübt
das wird das ist es wahrscheinlich warum
das ist ja der trial modus des todes das ist ja schlimmer das ist ja schlimmer als
warzone gerade meine güte du hast ja wirklich gerade überhaupt keine ruhe pass auf ich sag
euch jetzt klickt spmm jetzt ist vorbei als das cute squad am start ist sagt bescheid
kann ich euch wieder entweiten hast halt zu wenig häuser du hast generell zu wenig architektur
die häuser halt auch zu wenig architektur in den häusern es ist halt es ist halt lagerhaus
mit einer kiste drin die drehen die heizung auf ja fürcht ich auch hallo ich habe dich
gecancelt wie so eurer bisherige eindruck vom game macht schon richtig bock aber es hat
so krass viele bugs und probleme das ist auch so ein ding du hast ja du hast guck mal passt
mal auf ich release jetzt hier also ich gebe jetzt auf und ich kann mehr oder weniger instant
wieder rein spawnen guckt euch das mal an ins es lohnt sich gar nicht liegen zu bleiben
es ist und dementsprechend hast du auch ein komplett einen dauerhaften ansturm auf auf
alle flanken und und das nicht mit 32 spielen nein mit 64 spieler das kannst du das kannst
du einfach das geht einfach nicht geht einfach nicht keine chance aber wie blies hört mal
auf so rum zu zucken gegner komplett unpredictable das ist wie a d a d a d spam in overwatch
oh next hier wir gehen jetzt mal nicht aufs haus ich wollte ich wollte heute eigentlich
richtig entspannt mal alle anderen specialist ausprobieren so aber es geht da gar nicht
das ist ja hier der der schwitzer modus aktiviert wir können nicht und und das ist auch so
ein ding was mir an der map gar nicht gefällt nein das meine ich nicht es gibt keine flanck
möglichkeiten es gibt nichts es gibt den tunnel das war es und durch den tunnel kann
es nicht durch ich meine der tunnel der tunnel ist irgendwie zwei mann breit vergisst es
einfach also ich habe es schon von vielen gehört das game ist eine katastrophe und
ich gebe euch auch recht ich meine ich habe ein video dazu gemacht ich denke dass du die
hälfte der probleme die jetzt auf und auf offensichtlich haben also offensichtlich sind die auch viele
haben die kannst du relativ gut beheben ja dass das irgendwie rum klitsch dass du wenn
du den grappling hook benutzt und zu schnell bist dass du ins map aus rein klitschst und
so das kannst du alles beheben wo es schwieriger wird zu beheben sind halt so die die design
entscheidung ja zum beispiel so eine map zu bauen oder oder ein specialist wie webster
zu bauen der halt mehr op ist als so ziemlich alles andere was es gibt dass die spawns halt
auch unfair sind wenn du rein spawnst dann spawnst du hinter den gegnern die quasi gerade
versuchen die flagge einzunehmen was gar nicht anders geht weil du musst ja mit den
30 spieler die da rein spawnen an einer flagge irgendwo hin also es ist wirklich also viel
es ist da glaube ich bei design was dann richtig funktioniert warum sieht man auf der map nicht
wie groß der flaggenradius ist ja sowas gehe ich davon aus dass kriegen die schon noch
hin bin ich jetzt aus der queue geflogen
meinst du das lässt sich alles noch fixen jaja also so dieses rumgeklitsche und das
zeug das auf jeden fall wie gesagt aber halt die design entscheidung da ist ja hier am
start halt diese halt diese design entscheidung die ich gerade angesprochen habe die sind
ja bewusst getroffen auch dass jede seite die gleichen specialist hast die alle gleich
aussehen und sowas in der richtung es wurde ja bewusst getroffen ich verstehe nicht warum
es da nicht zumindest team haben gibt ja dass sie nicht alle komplett gleich aussehen aber
das wurde ja alles bewusst getroffen deswegen habe ich so meine zweifel ob sich da noch
irgendwie großartig was ändert die können vieles von dem spiel fixen aber einige sachen
sind halt auch einfach schlecht schlecht durchdacht und bots wurden ja groß angekündigt also
bots werden auf jeden fall drin bleiben und bots halte ich für eines der blödesten ideen
was es gibt was ist das denn das ist die open beta die seit weitach läuft und es fühlt
sich auch wirklich an wie beta aber es ist vom release also vom zeitpunkt her ist es
eigentlich eher so eine so eine typische beta demo dies jahr öfters jetzt in letzter zeit
öfters gibt es ja im trend sowas zu machen nur mit dem unterschied dass es sich an viel
für die beta aber vom vom datum her halt nicht passt walking simulator ja übrigens
man kann hier ich zeige euch das einfach mal was angucken kann also die haben die haben
sich schon was beigedacht also du hast ja gewisse abkürzung aber das ist dann im vergleich
zum rennen tatsächlich sogar noch relativ langsam und du kannst dadurch dass du einen
geraden fahrt nimmst ziemlich einfach abgeschossen werden also erst mal 30.000 stunden bis ich
hier oben bin und jetzt quasi direkt auf die gegner zu also wenn die mich jetzt nicht
beschen dann weiß ich auch nicht es sei denn das ist uns weiß ich ob das uns ist das ist
nicht uns okay hat mich gebetet
hier unten geht was da next please und dann sagt mir mal einer webster ist nicht okay
okay okay alles klar
direkt direkt vom auto was ich übrigens nicht gehört habe das auto hat sich für mich angehört
als ist es irgendwie fünf kilometer weg funktioniert die grab hook an fahrzeugen ja aber du kannst
dich nicht hochziehen du ziehst dich nur hoch bis zum heli und und
schwitzer modus ist aktiviert hier schmerz schmerz und kommt der pence man alda es ist
ja schlimm gerade was ist heute los du kannst ja keine fünf meter mehr gehen und dass die
gegner voll scharf auf diesen jetzt mal ernsthaft seht ihr den unterschied zu gestern gestern
war easy mode easy na gut die leute sind wahrscheinlich einfach schon wieder weg was
gehen wir
zu
Alter jetzt ist Battlefield, jetzt ist Battlefield angesagt hier, jetzt ist richtig Battlefield,
jetzt machts bock, please move deinen komischen Kopf, du machst nix, da machst du nix,
hätte er mal seinen Kopf da rausgemoved, das sind die, die von gestern spielen, die haben
gestern die ganze Zeit geübt und die Noobs sind weg, jetzt ist Tryhard Modus angesagt,
jetzt ist hier kein Spaß, kein Spaß mehr, jetzt wird, jetzt kickt SBMM oder was auch immer genau
kickt, ich weiß es nicht, achja und die Heli, die Heli Flieger haben es jetzt auch gecheckt,
wie es funktioniert, wo ist hier was, kann ich den Heli bashten vielleicht, wo ist er,
jetzt, ok wir fahren jetzt mal ein Stückchen, ok Anti-Air useless, du brauchst ja drei Stunden
bis du den abgeschossen hast, das hat keinen Sinn, ok gehen wir, ne wir gehen hier rein,
lass mich spawn, spawn, spawn, spawn, spawn, spawn please spawn, spawn, spawn, spawn, spawn in
combat null, nein, nein, nein, spawn, spawn, spawn, spawn, jawoll, easy, so muss das sein,
Oben ist auch noch einer, ich hab'n gesehen.
Meine Güte hier!
Das ist tryhard as fuck gerade.
Das ist ja nicht normal, das ist ja wie Warzone.
Das ist ja legit wie Warzone gerade.
Alter, das ist ja, du musst ja dein Herz rausspielen, Al.
Und die Helis brecken dich weg.
Ich will das keine Meter.
Das ist aber wirklich ein mega Unterschied zu gestern.
Also entweder sind bloß noch die ganzen, die ganzen tryhard Profis am Start oder es kickt
jetzt echt SBMM.
Wobei das merkwürdig wäre, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass hier wirklich irgendwas
SBMM ist.
Ich such gleich ein neues Game, wo wir die Heli-Basher haben.
Ich seh' nix.
Wie ist Teamplay, gibt's nicht, nicht vorhanden.
Hat jemand verstanden, was dieses Uniform-Game ist, nee.
Raketen.
Ich kann Raketen, aber da hab ich keinen Medipack.
Ich kann das da einpacken.
Engineer Package.
Das sackt aber.
Da krieg ich, da, da, pass mal auf, das probier'n wir jetzt aus.
Und das ist nicht Lock-On, oder, ist das Lock-On?
Okay, jetzt muss ich mich eigentlich gleich heilen.
Ist das Ding Lock-On?
Mein Gott, Alter!
Lasst mich mal in Ruhe.
Die spielen echt um ihr Leben gerade.
Scheiß.
Achtung!
Angeblich sind die Gegner um mich drum herum, ich weiß nicht wo.
Ich weiß nicht wo Gegner sind.
Alter, Alter, Alter, meine Güte!
Also, da kann ich ja Warzone spielen.
Ah, Serious Max willst du mitmachen?
Ich komm' noch nicht mal hier irgendwo auf den Heli zu schießen.
Äh, meinst du das Game profitiert von Pre-Made-Squads, ja, auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall, auf jeden
Fall profitiert es von Pre-Made-Squads.
Komm' mal, die haben mich schon wieder gespotted, die wissen schon, dass ich da bin.
Okay, wir probieren, Alter, die da oben stellen sich schon.
Ich hab' noch nie mal ne Chance dahin zu kommen.
Okay, vielleicht, vielleicht, vielleicht kriegen wir's hin.
Man sieht ja immer gute Plays dabeizwischen durch, aber...
Ah, Alter, nicht hängen bleiben, der weiß doch, dass ich da bin.
Okay, mal gucken, ob wir das schaffen.
Hopp, dachte, hier ist einer.
Jetzt spawnen, Achtung, passt auf Leute, jetzt ist nichts los und gleich spawnen 30 Leute
rein und wir werden geregt.
Ist so, passt auf, passt auf, die spawnen gleich hier rein.
Das ist immer so, es ist nichts los, das ist das, was ich meine, dass du es eigentlich
kaum defenden kannst, weil hier gleich 30, 40 Leute reindrücken.
Hier hinten ist übrigens gerne beliebt für spawnen.
Okay, keiner gespornet, okay, ich hab' nix gesagt, aber normalerweise ist das so.
Muss man nicht verstehen.
Ich geh' nicht an die Zip-Line, definitiv nicht.
Okay, mal probieren's trotzdem mal, ich kann, ich kann mich ja immer noch, Achtung, Achtung,
da ist einer.
Muss ich anstelzen von hinten.
Dass es hier blau wird hat glaub, what the fuck ist hier, was, was passiert hier gerade
wieder?
Was, Stream lag, wirklich?
Stream lagged?
Oh, Vodafone.
Vodafone.
Was ist hier los?
Jetzt sollte es wieder gehen, sollte wieder gehen, es sollte wieder gehen.
Ich hab' Frametrops, das lag an Vodafone, es liegt prinzipiell immer an Vodafone, wenn
man Frametrops hat.
Wo geht hier unten was, captchern die, captchern doch.
Okay, okay, bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wo hier was geht, nein, nein, lass mich in Ruhe.
Wie, das ist er wirklich evaded jetzt, oder was?
Shit, okay, das war, das, das, das hab ich jetzt verkackt.
Läuft wieder, ja, das war Mist von Vodafone, kannste nichts machen, schon verloren.
Ich glaube, wir sind einfach nur in einem brutalen Tryhard-Game gelandet.
Mal gucken, wir suchen uns danach einen anderen Server, einfach dodgen, einfach dodgen.
Oh, gleich starten die Rakete.
Vodafone, die Waffe ist auch deutlich zu OP, muss ich jetzt, muss ich jetzt einfach mal
loswerden.
Übrigens, die Helis, es wäre halt mega nice, wenn man die Helis hört, weil aktuell hörst
du die Helis, als sind sie 200 Meter weg und es ist nix.
Und was ihr hier auch seht, das Ding hat, also es hat insgesamt wenig Zerstörung, was
aber auch Sinn ergibt, stell dir mal vor, auf der Map könntest du was zerstören, auf
der Map gibt's ja jetzt schon nix.
Überlegt euch mal, auf dieser flachen Map, da fühlen sich Flat Earther richtig wohl.
Und dann könntest du noch die Häuser kaputt machen, das ist, dann ist RIP, stell dir vor,
das Haus kannst du kaputt machen, dann kannst du hier, guck mal, wenn das Haus kaputt ist,
dann könntest du von dem, von der Seite der Map bis auf die andere Seite der Map gucken,
so wenig ist da in der Mitte.
Flat Earther hassen diesen Trick.
Oh ne.
Übrigens, die zweite Kanatenexplosion hat man nicht gehört.
Alter, das ist einfach durchgeflogen, hab das ge-, einfach durch, komplett, komplett durch.
Das ist einfach komplett, komplett durch, 10 Kugeln, komplett.
Also, Serious Bugs, wenn du mitspielen willst, sag Bescheid, Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, RIP,
die größten Lager halten, da konnte man früher auch nicht verstärken, jaja, das ist aber
doch egal, nur weil man das früher nicht konnte, dann ist es trotzdem, ähm, dann kann
man das ja hier anders machen und dementsprechend das Level so bauen, dass du zumindest ein
bisschen Zerstörung hast, das ist ja, naja, aber in dem Fall, das geht ja nicht anders,
das geht ja nicht anders, sonst könntest du ja wirklich von, von der linken Seite der
Map auf die rechte Seite der Map gucken, was, was, was ja nicht, was hier nicht gewollt
sein kann.
Okay, wir machen jetzt YOLO, YOLO Move, was anderes bleibt uns nicht übrig.
Anderes bleibt uns übrig, weil wir nicht unten drunter durch können.
Da ist was innen drinnen, okay, die sterben grad, da hinten geht wieder was, der ist down
unter uns, okay, den haben wir, da hinten war noch mehr, jawoll, gib, gib alles, mach
so blatt, ich lasse, ich stelle dich jetzt in die Mitte der Base ab, ich stelle dich
jetzt in die Mitte der Base, shit, der hat die bessere Pose gehabt.
Cute Squad, ja, es bämmt mich mal ein bisschen voll, wenn ihr, äh, wenn ihr da seid, da
gehen wir rein, pass auf, Poggers, Poggers Five Head Place, komm jetzt, big brain time,
Base auf dem Dach, wusste ich, jetzt spawnen 50 Gegner um uns, Achtung, so, man muss definitiv
in Bewegung bleiben, wenn du nicht in Bewegung bleibst, hast du gleich gelost.
Pass auf, der andere Dude kommt gleich nochmal hoch, oder er wurde gekillt grad, der ist
vom Fallschirm jetzt runter gesprungen, hast du den Friendly Crest geschickt, Zack, ne,
ich hatte dich doch gestern schon drinnen, oder, ich hatte dich doch gestern schon drinnen,
äh, wie ging das jetzt hier nochmal, Social, PC, Demko ist am Start, da ist er, Base, komm,
lass mich rein, jawoll, jawoll, ganz schlecht die Idee, ganz, alter, diese, diese nicht,
diese nicht interpolierten Bewegungsmuster, Mann, kannst du überhaupt nicht predikten,
so wie das Eleonore Jumped, nice, wir haben es, auf der anderen Seite, auf der anderen
Seite sind noch welche, oder auch nicht, Achtung, wo ist er, wo ist er, eben war er
noch da, man sieht halt nichts, könnte ich jetzt spotten, dann könnte ich ihn sehen,
aber nope, alter, Halle in der Halle, morgen um neun Uhr, ja, morgen neun Uhr, oh, ich werde
gerätzt, nein, ich werde nicht gerätzt, doch, ich wurde gerätzt, fuck, danke, oh, oh, da
kommt was, ich muss weg, ok, ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, was hier abgeht, also ich
muss sagen, die ersten Tage haben die nichts gecheckt, was, ähm, Helis angeht, mittlerweile
sind die, sind die guten Helileute am Start und du wirst permanent geschreckt, ich kann
dich nicht holen, da ist der Heli am Start, oh, ich hab was gehitted, guck mal, Keg-Wade,
den holen wir jetzt, Baschen, alter, Baschen, fuck, das ist einer von mir gewesen, erstmal,
erstmal, macht ihr das auch immer so, erstmal den Zaun durchgeboxt, erstmal den Zaun durchgeboxt,
man, ich will aufs Dach und nicht hier rein, komm on, kannste nicht hin, ich müsste halt
hören, wo der Heli ist, ich höre den Heli nicht, da ist er, man hört die nicht, echt
dumm, jaja, Heli ist gut, oh, der Pantsman ist da, der Pantsman ist da, ok, vorbei, welche
beiden FPS-Anzeigen ist genau, ich würde sagen, die linke, äh, die rechte, die rechte, die
rechte ist nämlich die In-Game-Anzeige, guck mal, es gibt übrigens keinen Respawn-Elay,
den Peter geht bis morgen 9 Uhr, ok, das war klar, dass der das up-aimt, hätte ich auch
so gemacht, retz mich nicht, renn weiter, renn weiter, ich kann eh gleich rein-spawn
bei euch, easy, guck, kein Respawn-Timer, keck wait, oh, jetzt müssen wir aufpassen,
fuck, der macht das so wie ich gestern, ich seh ihn, ich seh ihn, aha, six hat move, ok,
jetzt muss ich hier irgendwie hoch, lass mich rauf, das hast du dir so gedacht, du Sack,
das habt ihr euch so gedacht, jetzt spawnen die da unten, oh, oh, oh, oh, 50 Gegner, 50
Milliarden Gegner, 5 Trillionen Gegner am Start, wo ist er, unter mir ist er, Achtung, Achtung,
ich krieg 17, how to, how to Seite wechseln auf dem Hochhaus, what the hell ist da unten
los, meine Güte, von wo, von wo alter, ich bleib jetzt hier liegen, ich glaub's nicht,
da kommt er gestellt, so musst du's machen, lass mich rein, lass mich rein, spawnen, spawnen,
was davon ist denn jetzt, bitte schön da spawnen, geil, top, nice, GG, ich wusste gar nicht,
was ich da vorn anklicken muss zum spawnen, vielleicht hab ich Glück und der, der, ich
kann, nein, ok, RIP, äh, dann können wir wahrscheinlich mal A1, A1 wird eingenommen,
ich guck gleich Chat nach der Runde, ich mach das gerne so, mal kurz peeken in der Hoffnung,
die schießen auf mich, weil Gegner siehst du hier nicht, wenn die auf mich schießen,
dann hab ich vielleicht Glück, guck, guck, wenn die schießen, dann siehst du sie, oh,
die Heli, Heli Dutz sind wieder da, Heli Dutz sind da, ey, wir haben gut aufgeholt, guck
mal, Poggers, wir gewinnen das noch, richtig nice, oh, oh, oh, lass mich in Ruhe, ja, ich
wusste, dass du mich siehst, pass mal auf, oh, nix wie weg, nade, nade, komm mal, nade
hat gehitted, oh, oh, rechts kommt ganz viel, what the fuck, der hängt, der ist an der Luft,
der hängt einfach da, hier, was auch immer, machst richtiger Cue-Streamer, also es ist
im Vergleich zu gestern wirklich, das ist der Schwitzer-Modus, gestern sind wir hier
rumgehüpft, ja, gehen wir mal aufs Dach, bashen wir mal ein paar Leute und heute musst
wir permanent wufen, gucken, machen, tun, oh, oh, oh, Alter, warum ist der blau, warum
ist der blau, der ist überhaupt nicht in meinem Team, she baited, kann ich dazu nur sagen,
you got, she baited, was ist nochmal der Lockon-Raketenwerfer, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, ich hab Angst,
der Heliman, wer ist denn der Heliman, jemand der das kann, ich bin auf dem Kopf, oh, oh,
oh, da wird sie ja schlecht bei, wo ist sie oben, wo ist sie unten, ok, man muss sich
glaube ich dran gewöhnen, dass es permanent tutet, ist unser Schütze tot, ne, unser Schütze
noch, ah, der rappt gerade, glaub, der rappt, haben wir den Treffen hier oder, naja, naja,
du denkst permanent, du stürzt ab, Mensch, Alter, what the, wow, also, motion sickness
hier, vom Dach, vom Dach, ich hab irgendwas vom Dach springen sehen, weiß nicht, ob das
meiner war, oder auch nicht, by the way, keine Bots heute, guck, guck, jetzt spawnen, guck,
seht ihr Leute, 30, easy win, habt ihr es gesehen, kaum nimmst du ein, auf einmal spawnen
20 Leute um dich drum herum, das war zwar, sag mal, wenn du Bazaar, Conquest gespielt
hast, ähnlich, aber nicht so extrem, dass die quasi um dich im Kreis gespawnt haben,
bin weit mal, mach ich, ah, ich easy win, also für die 30 Kills heute, musste dich schon
wirklich deutlich mehr anstrengen, als für die 40 gestern, bis wann geht die Beta noch,
9 Uhr morgen früh, sind jetzt quasi die letzten Runden, die wir spielen, der Serious Max,
so ist er, da, Bäm, den Wight ist raus, so, ich guck mal ein bisschen Chat, hab ich irgendwas
übersehen, glaubst du da ist, wenn sie sagen, sie hätten so viele Bugs aus der Beta bereits
gefixt, ja, das Spiel hat so viele Bugs, wenn du viele Bugs schon gefixt hast, sind immer
noch viele da, warum die angeblich in 7 Monaten alten Stand veröffentlicht haben, verstehe
ich nicht, Error, noch mal, wo ist er, ich kann nicht noch mal, du bist angeblich drin,
soll ich hier nochmal kicken, ich kann hier nicht kicken, einmal drin, immer drin, guck
mal, ob es jetzt geht, das Game lädt, also ja, die haben bestimmt schon viele Bugs gefixt
aus der Beta, aber wenn du viele Bugs gefixt hast, dann ist immer noch viele Bugs vorhanden,
nein, oh, oh, ich bin doch richtig gespawnt, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, aber Game lädt, ja,
das ist, Battle, wait a minute, ich bin Medic jetzt, ok, dann spielen wir jetzt Medic, wobei
ich nicht lange Medic spiele, das halte ich nicht aus, ich brauche Movement in dem Spiel,
zockst du noch Konsole, ne, ab und zu mal, wobei ich die, ich habe mir keine PS5 gekauft,
auch keine Xbox Series X, erste Konsolen Generation seit Jahrzehnten, die ich mir nicht kaufe,
sterben please, oh, ne, bei mir ist was, ne, oh, ich hole dich, pass mal auf, Defi stellts
als Medic, der ist minimal schneller nur, so und hier, ne, jetzt ist der schon released,
die Leute wissen ja auch nicht, dass ich komme zum retzen, die wissen es nicht, ja, wenn
man Webster spielt, kannst du eigentlich nichts anderes mehr spielen, ich renne jetzt schon
wieder aufs Haus los, weil ich denke, ich kann aufs Dach, aber ich kann ja gar nicht
aufs Dach, was macht man da jetzt eigentlich, nix, warten, warten bis wir von der Seite
weggestellts werden oder vom Dach, warten bis wir vom Dach gebashed werden, haha, kreckt,
genau, war nicht alles kaputt hier, Greenpeace ist informiert, so, gehen wir aufs Dach, nein,
wir gehen nicht aufs Dach, alter, ich kacke, ey, wie kann man sich selbst heilen als Medic,
wir haben uns gegenseitig gekillt, oh man, ok, Medic time over, Leute, als Sider nicht
werd geressen, nein, Mensch nicht, Medic time over, ah, broken, Dach, Medic, es ist halt
auch krass OP, wenn du dir mal überlegst, du kannst die beste Mobility nehmen und zusätzlich,
Crabbling Hook, auch nicht, schon wieder Game, wie oft denn noch, das hatten wir gestern
schon 5 mal oder so, so ein Müll, oh, Selbstmordtunnel hier, da bist du immer down, das ist gewollt
um den Hook zu balancen, na klar, na klar, übrigens, sehr gutes Comment, weil, das ein
typisches YouTube Comment sein könnte, ich weiß, du, für dich, hallo, rettot, please,
ich seh nix, das könnten typisches, das könnten typisches YouTube Comment sein, Max, Max,
was erzählst du denn da für einen Blödsinn in deinem Video, das ist sicherlich Absicht
um den Hook zu balancen, ich kann mir dieses Comment auf YouTube eins zu eins vorstellen,
ich weiß, du meinst, du meinst als Gag, aber das ist so ein typisches Low IQ, 3 Head, YouTube
Comment, also wenn das auf YouTube einer, nicht du, wenn das auf YouTube einer gepostet
hätte, ich kanns mir richtig bildlich, ich seh es bildlich vor mir, das Comment, ist
echt so, Monka, wie viele, Billionen Leute, ich bin immer noch nicht sicher, ob 128 Spieler
wirklich ne gute Idee war, wisst ihr, wie ich mein, der ist aufgeklatscht, der hat's
sich rechtzeitig hingekriegt, bin mir noch unschlüssig, ob 128 Spieler ne gute Idee war,
ich bin unschlüssig, not sure if serious hier, ich bin mir echt unschlüssig, ob das
ne gute Idee war, dadurch hast du viel größere Map, viel größere Skalierung, alles ist kleiner,
weil du die Spieler irgendwie unterbringen musst und du hast so ne clusterfuck Action
wie das hier, okay, gut, nice GD, what the fuck, der will mich outplayen, pass mal auf,
ich krieg 17, der denkt jetzt, er kommt von hinten und du kommst nicht von hinten, ich
komm von hinten an, gachi bass, alter, gachi bass, Mist, mein Mini-Pack ist nicht ready,
ich fahr um die Eck, ne, hier retzt mich keiner, ne, ich muss mal kurz was gucken, auf geht's,
wo gehen wir hin, wird hier gecaptured, warum kann ich hier nicht spawnen, das ist ein Bug,
hallo, ah ne, wir capturen den, wir verlieren den nicht, wir verlieren den nicht, wir capturen
den gerade, geh zu meinem Team, besser, okay, wo gehen wir hin, sagt an, okay, sagt an,
wenn alle nur, also sagt an ist ein ziemlich doofes Comment, es gibt kein Textchat, es
gibt kein Ingame Emotes, wir sind nicht im TS, wie sollen sie ansagen, sag an, du hast
keine Möglichkeit was anzusagen, aber sag an, warum, Ansage ist, bashen, bashen ist
die Ansage, es muss reichen, oh nice, ich komm rein, es hat nur einen Sitz, ne, jawoll,
fehlt, fehlt er in der Mitte des Bildschirms nicht irgendwas, seid ihr nicht auch der Meinung,
in der Mitte des Bildschirms ist irgendwas missing, oh, und warum rockelt das schon wieder
so, Hardcore gibt kein Crosshair, Tracer Rounds, Tracer Rounds, sag mal, nein, nice, GG Eats,
nein, nein, nein, komm her, entschuldige, nein, ich will nicht reviven, ich will nicht
deine Waffe aufheben, Teamplay, Porgas für Teamplay wieder, Porgas für Teamplay, sofern
es in dem Spiel möglich ist, sofern es möglich ist, ich hole dich, oh fuck, hier explodiert
alles, und, und, und, pschu, übrigens diese Wiederbeleb-Animation ist auch maximal unbefriedigend,
ich fand es vorher viel besser, Defi rausholen und Defi reiben und dann pschu, kurz um die
Ecke pieken, aber das, wer hat gedacht, das ist eine gute Idee, absolut, warum überhaupt
was ändert, ich hab eh das Gefühl, ich weiß nicht, was DICE macht, jetzt mal ernsthaft,
muss ich mal zum Schluss werden, warum fangen die gefühlt jedes Battlefield von Null an
zu entwickeln, es wirkt irgendwie so, die haben eine gute Sache in einem alten Battlefield,
was machen sie im nächsten Battlefield, sie bauen sie irgendwie anders kaputt neu ein,
und why, ich mein, ich bin jetzt der Letzte, der sich irgendwie der Recycling gerne möchte,
ihr wisst, ich find es auch nicht geil, Fifa, Fifa und Fifa und Fifa, aber so paar, so paar
Mechanics in Game hier, oder sei es nur ein funktionierendes Battle-Lock oder irgendwas,
die müssen doch nicht jedes Battlefield immer komplett von Null anfangen, und die haben
immer die gleichen Probleme, Server desync, Hit-Track, alles mögliche, und das patchen
sie dann über die nächsten zwei Jahre in einem Game, aber das in dem alten Game funktioniert
es ja schon, sind einfach planlos, aber die sollten ja zumindest ein Spiel entwickeln
können, ich mein, sie sollten ja zumindest das, was sie schon mal gemacht haben, nochmal
machen können, oder aber, wenn nicht nochmal machen können, dann behalten von dem alten,
ne, wisst ihr mich mal so, oder Selbstmord-Tunnel, schlechte Idee Leute, ganz schlechte Idee,
ganz schlechte Idee, ich aim mal ab, ich komm eh nicht durch, ach, auf der anderen Seite
ist uns, ok, dann könnte es doch sein, ach, ihr seid schon auf der anderen Seite, ok,
ich hab nix gesagt, Arenax, ich versuch dich zu holen, aber ich bin Pitchmeter weg, glaub
das wird nix, ohoh, ohoh, ohoh, easy win, easy win, Leute, Leute, wir müssen mal kurz
was machen, während das lädt, während das lädt, wir müssen kurz was machen, ehm, wie
gesagt, bekannter von mir, casted grad solo, Valorant, geht mal please, im zweiten Tab,
geht mal please hier hin, und spammt einmal kurz im Chat, Wupppock, einfach nur Wupppock
spamm, da freut er sich, da können wir wirklich jemand erfreuen, einfach mal Wupppock, Wupppock,
jeder der will, da freut er sich auf jeden Fall, so, weiter, next game, Arenax, bist
du raus, oder bist du, ah, bist du grad erst rein, nur für Follower, was, ernsthaft, ist
das Follower only Chat, low IQ Chatmod Settings man, ok, dann, dann haben sie Pech, dann,
dann nicht, kann ich, kann ich auch nix machen, wenn man Follower only hat, warum macht man
Follower only bei 400 Zuschauern, oder weiß ja grad nicht gesehen, wieviel sie grad haben,
aber, but why, wieso hab ich mehr GPU-Auslösung bei Max im Stream als in Battlefield 2042,
wahrscheinlich weil du ne Grafikkarte hast und deine CPU, ehm, in Däumchen dreht, also
du hast ne, wahrscheinlich ne OP, OP, ehm, CPU und ne Sucker-Grafikkarte, es gibt jetzt
SMS verified only Chat, warum soll ich denn sowas machen, das ist ja un-cute, Ayaya verified
wäre ok, aber also, ansonsten, ach heute, jetzt weiß ich auch warum ich da so komisch
anhalte, ich hab heute so ne, sowas hier, so ne Jacke mit, mit Kreisverschluss an, das
bleibt die ganze Zeit am Kabel, weiß ich auch was das für ein komisches Geräusch ist,
so, zack, zack, zack, pock, next please, kann man irgendwo da ne Hardware sehen, ok, 8700k,
10008G, ich weiß nicht ob wir Ausrufezeichen Specs oder sowas haben, ich glaub wir haben
Ausrufezeichen Specs, ich bin mir, der Halo-Tunnel ist hier, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
es Ausrufezeichen Specs ist, da oben ist was gelandet, was hab ich denn hier jetzt, what
the fuck ist das, ist das der Sniper Dude, oh ne ich bin als Sniper gespawnt, RIP, ich
bin als Sniper gespawnt, wo man wieder sieht warum Webster so OP ist, du kommst einfach
überall hin, die müssten jedem Specialist ein bisschen Mobility geben, dann wär das
wieder ok, aber so, was kann der, was kann der Dude eigentlich, ah ja, guter Spot Kollege,
guter Spot, check ich mal was der kann, ah Dronenstelz, Dronenstelz, wo man nicht richtig
spotten kann, Dronenstelz, kann man damit schießen, ne, ja dann bringt ja der Dronenstelz
auch nur begrenzt was, oh na hier Leute ich spotte euch, ich spotte euch, ganz viel, ganz
viel, ganz viel hier, massive spotting, huge, 5 head, 6 head spotting, ok ich hab gespottet
jetzt wird gebashed, ok der hat mich outmoved, ok ich mach wieder Grappling Hook, das Sniper
Dude ist nicht mein, hast du schon mal versucht mit Webster auf die Rakete, ja ich habs nicht
geschafft auf die Spitze zu kommen, ich war dazu blöd für, Dronenroadkill, das muss man
tatsächlich später mal ausprobieren, really kid, schreien, das, starte das verdammte Spiel,
ok kein Hit, null W, BF3 mäßige Spotting immer ganz gut, BF3 Spotting war ein Tick
besser als Battlefield Bad Company Spotting, Bad Company Spotting war komplett verrückt,
BF3 Spotting ist in Ordnung gewesen, ich finde man muss es nicht übertreiben dass
jemand noch 5 Sekunden markiert bleibt durch die Wand, das muss nicht unbedingt sein, ich
mein du musst es sich ja nur einmal zu erkennen geben in Battlefield 3 und zack hat das ganze
Team auf dich geaimt, oh Mist das war ziemlich dumm, ok ich war auch fast schon oben auf der
Rakete, slide immer runter, ja ging mir genauso, oh wer ist gerätzt, nein Moment es ist kein
Squadmate von mir oder, ist das ein Squadmate, nee das ist kein Squadmate das sieht einfach
nur so aus, das ist Jebait Mate ist das, die Beta ist generell durch Conquest sehr langweilig
ja, ich finde es ist nicht nur Conquest die Map ist eigentlich das Ding, wenn man mal
Bazaar Conquest gespielt hat, man sieht man das kann auch brutal, mega intense sein ja,
da war was ich habe es gesehen, alles klar, Pepega, Pepega behind mir, komm lass dich
zeigen, zeig dich Mann, der hat eine Chris, da hätte ich keine Chance gehabt gegen die
im Nahkampf, keine Chance gehabt er, schrägt man, you got jebaited dude, glaube ich habe
gedacht das ist unser Heli oder, Hallo hier ist was, hier ist was ich sehe dich nicht
Mann, keine Chance Alter, was ist denn hier im Chat gerade wieder los, aber an dem Punkt
geht es jetzt wieder richtig zur Sache, lass mich rein spawnen, jawoll kein Respawn Timer
beste, der beste Respawn Timer ist kein Respawn Timer Achtung, oh nee, nee ich kack noob,
die sind doch hier auf dem Dach oder oder nicht, Triggerbot aktiviert, nee by the way
man kann das Ding in Burst Modus schalten, das ist total OP, die Pistole in Burst Modus,
Mods in Ingame, ja ihr habt gehört Mods sind auch noch Menschen die spielen wollen, schwer
zu glauben, wer weiß, schwer zu glauben, war nix, ist nix, man sieht auch so schlecht
was Alter, bis ihr in anderen Battlefield heilen konnt ich euch gleich sagen, der Pixel
da vorne ist was, hier nicht, keine Möglichkeit, oh wäre das nicht gut wenn ich die spotten
könnte, das wäre so nice, könnte man die spotten, Mods sind alive, ja habe ich auch
gehört, Mod check, ich renn mal meinem Team nach, wir machen jetzt wieder Poggers für
Teamplay, meine Frage an die Leute die es gespielt haben, findet ihr auch dass das gesamte
Geschwindigkeit von Laufen und Sliden und Timings sehr warzone ist, scheuert das Wort,
also sehr warzone ähnlich, also das wie lange du slidest, wie schnell du läufst, wie du
auf Gegner zu slidest, time to kill, wobei time to kill ein bisschen schneller ist als
es warzone, waren da gerade 5 Leute über mich drüber, sieht so aus, schreckt, ah nice,
wir spawnen hinter den Gegnern, ja klar, wenn ich meinen Red Dot ja sehen würde, wo ist
der Dude, alter schreckt man, in the cup, ich muss euch sagen Hatshots fallen wir in dem
Spiel leichter als in dem anderen Game, weiß auch nicht so genau woran das liegt, aber
ich meine es blinkt ja bei fast jedem zweiten Gegner, ich glaube die haben wahrscheinlich
einfach ne riesen Hatshot Box dass man sich gut fühlt, dieser grappling hook ist klassenbezogen
ja, deswegen ist es auch die einzig sinnvolle OP Klasse, wo ist er hin, oh ne Heli, Heli
stellt er, lass mich in Ruhe, gehst du weg, stells Heli, piss dich Alte, oh oh, pp guard
aimed, pp guard, weg pp guard, ich hatte keine Muni mehr, wie viele fps hast du, ich hab
extra zwei Sachen eingeplänt, links oben Origin, rechts oben in game, WTF das macht
halt die Klasse wirklich so einzig spielbar, hab ich ja auch immer im Video gesagt und
in YouTube Kommentaren wieder, ach Max, Webster ist gar nicht so gut, ich spiele lieber den
Typ mit dem Turm, wie weit musst du den vorhalten, ganz ehrlich also wer den Dude mit dem Turm
besser findet, der weiß nicht so genau was mit dem Spiel los ist, schreckt man, fack,
pass wieder drüben gewesen, oha Medipack, hast du noch was vom Friseur gehört, klar
ich hab mit dem Friseur vor einer Woche noch Diablo 2 gespielt, auf Metro ist der Typ
mit dem Turm sicher besser, weiß nicht, der Turm haut nicht so rein so richtig, also es
könnte sein, jetzt spawnen gleich, passt auf Leute, jetzt ist es ruhig und gleich spawnen
30 Leute, passt auf, seh mal so, es ist Paynes Champ dieses Spawnsystem, komm mal nichts
los, nichts los und gleich spawnen sie rein, 50 Gegner, oder sind grad woanders beschäftigt
aber es ist auf jeden Fall öfter so, ok wir nehmen schon nicht mal ein, das heißt die
Gegner sind da und nehmen wir doch noch ein, ich erkenne es nicht, oh wir haben es, easy,
ist gar nichts gespawnt, komisch, wir kriegen gerade brutalst auf den Sack, guckt euch das
mal an, Sand Crossing mit dem Grappling Hook, es gäbe auf Sand Crossing gar nicht so viel
außer die Apartments, die meisten Häuser in Battlefield 3 waren ja, also Häuser was
sahen in Battlefield 3 waren ja Zierde, da vorne ist was, ich bin dumm ich hab geschossen,
war richtig Pepega da zu schießen, als wüssten sie dass wir da sind, richtig Pepega, nice,
Midi Pack hier, oh pass auf hier unten sterben Leute, müssen wir gucken, irgendwo hier sind
die meisten, man sieht ja hier nix in dem Spiel, man sieht ja nix, und auch nochmal eine Frage,
mir gehts, ich finde die Lebensanzeige ist zu klein, normalerweise muss ich ganz kurz
nach rechts unten gucken und man sieht was, aber du hast sie überhaupt nicht im Augenwinkel
drin, oh da war rechts was, fliegt ne Granate, du hast sie überhaupt nicht richtig im Augenwinkel
drinne, ich muss immer 3 Sekunden hingucken, ganz ganz weird, weird Champ, oh man ich würd
euch so gerne spotten da hinten ihr Dudes, aber nope, no spotting for you, ich will da
nicht hoch, ich will da nicht hoch, da oben sind 50 Billiarden Gegner, oh man, oh man,
shit und um mich drum herum auch, nix wie weg man, ich seh nix, oh wir haben den Captain
hookt, habt ihrs gesehen wir haben den Captain hookt, ok hook ist nicht one shot, da kommt
was, hook ist nicht one shot, hier ist überhaupt kein first aid, mein first aid ist weg, alter
was ist das für ein Geschwitze heute, ich fass es nicht, ich streng mich ja wirklich
an aber du wirst von allen Seiten zerstört, was soll eigentlich dieser blaue Overlay,
das hab ich auch ne Weile kapiert, gebrauche ich das kapiere, das ist Kühlflüssigkeit
in diesen Tanks und wenn man da zu nah dran geht unterkühlt man, was außer das es doof
aussieht glaube ich keinerlei Auswirkungen hat, ok nice GG, perfekte Pose, gute Pose,
pass auf Nate auf den Kopf, oh der hat noch schneller gecheckt als ich, aber seht ihr
auch den Kontrast zu gestern, das ist Wahnsinn, ich glaube die HP regeneriert sich da nicht,
das kann sein, das konnte ich noch nicht beobachten, ok jolo, ja richtig schwitzig, du bist in der
Stabe, ok GG, meine Güte man, please, mach die Spieleranzahl runter, das ist echt krass,
das geht ja aber gar nicht, kann man die Mates auch schneller wiederbeleben, nein das Wiederbelebung
ist viel zu langsam, kannst du Mr. McCain an uns auspacken, ne, oh oh, da mal, Monka,
die sind links, rechts, vorne, oben, unten, hinten im Arsch, die überall sind die, die
stecken mir sogar hinten drin, so viele Gegner sind es hier, Monka, meine Güte was ist denn
hier los gerade, da stecken mir 3 Stück in Pobis, mindestens, es gibt ein neues Genre
mit 42, keine Ahnung, muss ich mir noch was ausdenken, oh in your Kopf, also heute schon
sehr schwitzig im Vergleich zu gestern, nein das wollte ich gar nicht, ich bin mir nicht
so sicher, wo der Dude hin ist, keine Ahnung, man weiß es nicht, man weiß es nicht, ihr
müsst nicht LULW schreiben, ihr müsst nicht LULW schreiben, ihr müsst nicht LULW schreiben,
ihr müsst doch nicht Omega LULW schreiben, der Crapling Hook ist in dem Moment weg, wo
ich gedrückt habe und dann konnte ich den Fallschirm nicht aufmachen, ihr müsst gar
nicht so tun, als hättet ihr das besser gemacht, wobei der Chat macht ja prinzipiell immer
alles besser, wissen wir ja, des wie sind wir ja, ne, das haben wir ja gelernt, äh what,
wenn der Chat was macht, dann macht er das eigentlich immer besser als der Streamer,
alles klar, das ich weiß, ich weiß, das ist ja ungeschriebenes Twitch Gesetz, oh ne, den
wollte ich jetzt noch wegstellen, not false LULW, heute ist wirklich anstrengend, wie
läuft die Hexe dabei, die Hexe basht immer, huge loss haben wir verloren, heute sind irgendwie
plötzlich alle krass, ist hart ne, also entweder sind die Noobs weg, nur noch die Tryhards
am Start, oder es kickt jetzt SBMM, hat man Statistik, hat man Statistik von sich selbst
irgendwie so, kd muss ich gucken, kd, hat man nicht, kd ist unwichtig, nein kd, kd ist
was die Youtube Views bringt, ganz einfach, stellt euch mal vor, es lädt einen den Gameplay
hoch, World Record, Battlefield 2042, Kill World Record, versus Objective Blade Record,
wo gucken mehr Leute drauf, hast du eigentlich die Ultimate oder die Gold Edition, keine
Ahnung, ich hab nen Code gekriegt, Codra, hatte ich sowas von 2012, was macht man denn
heute, ich weiß aus Warzone, die ganzen Leute, die per VPN oder Playstation Lobbys faken,
die machen immer World's First Kill Count World Record oder sowas, oder die Leute die
beispielsweise dann auch diese komischen Videos machen mit One versus Four Lobby, easy win,
und dann guckst du dir die Gameplays an und weißt, ok, der Typ hat erstmal drei Wochen
Reverse Boosted vor dem Gameplay, oder hat sich per VPN verbunden, oder joint über ein
Freundesaccount nach, aber spielt definitiv nicht gegen normale Gegner, wie umsonst nen
Code, ja vielleicht wollte EA mich bestechen, nee, keine Ahnung, ich hab insgesamt, ich
hab nen Code für mich gekriegt, und ich hab vier Codes gekriegt, zum verlosen, wobei
die hätte ich nicht verlosen, hätte ich auch Kollegen und Freunde geben können, äh,
es lohnt sich ja überhaupt nicht rein zu spawnen gerade, gehen wir da jetzt hin, erstmal
richtiges Ding ausrüsten, tja, lohnt sich gar nicht irgendwo hinzugehen, wird das hier
gecaptured gerade, wo ist denn hier was, ich warte einfach mal, ich warte einfach, wo gehen
wir denn hin, wo gehen wir denn hin, ah, hier wird gecaptured, ok, easy, tja, tja, die wissen
was ich da, achto, achto, huge nade, huge nade, massive, massive, ha, lol, ah, she baited,
mann, das hast du dir so gedacht, Alter, a bre naded, pass auf, die spawnen jetzt alle
hier oben, die spawnen jetzt hier oben, gleich wieder alle da, fünf Gegner, guck da drüben
ist schon wieder was gespornet, ey, das ist meiner, mein Dude, mein Dude, ist rawmouse
input eigentlich bugged, weiß ich nicht, standardmäßig eingeschaltet, äh, also es stimmt, es stimmt
auf jeden Fall irgendwas hier nicht, also maus technisch ist irgendwas definitiv nicht richtig,
das fühlt sich so, so übertrieben Scheibenwicher an in dem Spiel, da stimmt was nicht, gibts
hier ein Kommand, ich, Ausrufezeichen, stats, bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wenn nicht, wär
cool, wenn wir eins machen können, ich hab ne 1080 Ti und äh, äh, 8700k, also recht
in der drei jahre alt ist quasi, nichts irgendwie großartig neues, da wurde der gebashter,
du, äh, hallo, hallo, da ma, das ist doch auch ne warzone animation, oder, dieses Türe
aufhauen, das ist doch original, ich glaub die, langsam glaub ich immer noch mehr, äh,
die wollten eigentlich nen battle royale machen und haben festgestellt, battle royale ist
jetzt eigentlich schon zu stark besetzt und haben gesagt wir machen doch nen battlefield
an, plus ein jahr Entwicklungszeit, anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären hier, Achtung,
ich hab keine nades mehr, ok, das war dumm von mir da rein zu laufen, wenn die Tür vom
Gegner getappt wurde, vielleicht krieg ich nen Rats, oh, da kommen 50 Milliarden Gegner
rausgelaufen, nooo, schnell, schnell respawn, respawn, respawn am gleichen Punkt wieder
rein, jawoll, easy, gleichen Punkt wieder rein, ich hab ja keinen respawn timer, was
auch sehr undurchdacht ist, keinen respawn timer zu haben, also kein wirklich, wir haben
4 Sekunden respawn timer oder so, tja, das hat er sich, das haben die dudes sich anders
vorgestellt, alter lasst mich in Ruhe, heli stellts, mein güt ey, der heli dude willst
aber echt wissen jetzt, die hätt ich beide klatschen können, unterhand nadewurf geht,
äh, gute Frage, keine Ahnung, nö, nö, geht glaub ich nicht, du musst, du musst switchen,
du musst switchen, oder ich hab's ja nicht gecheckt, wenn du G drückst, switcht er eben
auf die, alter hier, hier, hier kannst du dich nicht bewegen, du kannst dich nicht
bewegen, hier sind zu viele, ihr kommt gleich was rein Leute, ich sag's euch, pass mal auf,
die kommen gleich rein hier, seriously, seriously, ernsthaft jetzt, ja, da wo ich stehe, genau
da sprengt der die wand in die luft, na klar, na klar, na klar, na klar, na klar, na klar,
na klar, na klar, na klar!"
Ansonsten verbugt das Fak und auch merkwürdige Design-Anscheidungen, zum Beispiel Bots, die
man so absichtlich eingebaut hat, die nicht einfach drin sind, auch wenn Youtube was anderes
sagt, weil sie es nicht besser wussten oder irgendwie, dass das gut ist, weil wenn das
Server nicht voll ist, ganz ehrlich, wenn der Server nicht voll ist, wer braucht Bots?
Wenn der Server nicht voll ist, geht man einfach runter und geht auf den vollen Server.
Pipehead!
Ist das zu kompliziert oder was?
Also wer braucht Bots in dem Spiel?
Weil ich ernst gemeinte frage, wer braucht Bots?
Ich hatte noch nie ein Problem mit leeren Servern in dem Game.
Im Battlefield allgemein.
Hoffentlich man klappt den Ruckball daaaa!
Da hinten ist einer, links ist einer, links ist einer, shit, shit, shit, shit, dahinten
ist...
Ja klar!
Natürlich!
Ich check gar nicht mal, was hier lebt und was nicht, ist mir zu hoch.
Vor allem, was ist hier gerade los?
Okay, wir benutzen jetzt mal was, was das Game von uns möchte, das wir benutzen.
Okay, so und ich.
Six-Set-Time.
Vielleicht sollte ich nicht komplett sprayen, aber warum eigentlich nicht, das ist, wenn
man das ein bisschen geübt hat, ist es auf jeden Fall sprayable.
Komm raus!
Was sag ich doch, sprayable ist das?
Das ist ja noch besser als das andere.
Wo ist eigentlich mein Team, da ist einer, da ist einer, ich weiß nicht, wo die anderen
sind.
Ah, hier, nice, GG Eats.
Oh, da ist was unter uns.
Oh, ich hab keine Nades mehr, shit.
Ich wollte eigentlich ein paar Nades ins Auto schmeißen.
Lass mich in Ruhe.
By the way, Webster ist der einzige Specialist, der man spielen kann.
Wer es mir jetzt bis jetzt nicht geglaubt hat, hoffentlich glaubt es mir jetzt.
Wie willst du das Kontern hier, wie willst du das Kontern?
Oder wie der echte Gangster sagen würde, was willst du tun?
Nix, machst du dagegen.
Oh, huge aim, so machst du es, genau, so muss es sein.
Fuck, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nicht retzen, mach dir blatt, fuck,
nein, der kommt von hinten, in the ass.
Ich hab die Bilder zwar nur kurz gespielt, aber es ist einfach ohne Sensitivity-Einstellung
unspielbar.
Wieso?
Man hat doch Sensitivity-Einstellung.
Es ist bloß trotzdem schwammig, wieso?
So useless.
Oh, das war ein cooler Play, oder?
Es ist alles auf Low, nein, ich spiele nicht auf Ultra.
Wenn ich auf Ultra spiele, sind die Frames auch nicht, sag mal so, zwar nicht so bedeutend,
niedriger, aber niedriger.
Also es läuft nicht, für Low läuft das nicht gut.
Okay, war vielleicht so jetzt.
Da war doch hier was.
Wieder weg penetriert.
Ich finde, hier müsste es noch einen Tunnel geben.
Es müsste hier einen Tunnel geben, es müsste da hinten einen Tunnel geben, es müsste da
einen Tunnel geben, es müsste mindestens vier Tunnel geben, dass du ordentlich flenken
kannst.
Aktuell gibt es einfach zu wenig Tunnel.
Und am besten hier noch irgendetwas hin machen, man könnte doch sagen, hey, das ist kaputt
geschossen worden, hat hier noch ein paar Wald, du brauchst definitiv, du brauchst mehr auf
der Map.
Die Map sieht wie random generated aus und dann ein paar Essens draufgestellt, das sieht
doch nicht nach einer fertig komplett durchdachten designten Map aus.
Das ist nix, lull ich hab den erwischt, hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Achtung, ah Mist, wo ist er, wo ist er, nirgendswo.
Ah Moment, Ding switchen.
Hier ist nix mehr, ah doch daneben, lull, du hörst den Hedy nicht und du fliegst einfach
in die Luft.
Also Chet sagt, also mir hat das Spiel bisher nicht gefallen, ich bin echt hin und her gerissen,
es macht auf der einen Seite wirklich Bock, aber es hat so viele merkwürdige Sachen einfach
nur.
Hä, war das ein Gegner gerade?
Es hat so viele merkwürdige Sachen und merkwürdige Designentscheidungen, wie gesagt Bots ist ja
nur das offensichtlichste.
Pass mal auf, Torgas Modus, ha, lull, wirklich, seriously, äh hallo, seriously was war das
gerade für nen Hook, das ist ja fast schon Apex Pathfinder mäßig.
Ok, next, hier müssen wir hin, da ist noch einer, der ist super Schleicher, um's
in Max Sprache zu sagen der Super Stelzer, Massive Stelzer, hat ihm aber auch nix gebracht,
dass er so nice stellst.
Aha, Team was haltet ihr vom Hochhaus, aufs Hochhaus hinten rum, Max ich hol dich, falls
hier safe ist, ich kann dich nicht holen, kann dich nicht holen, weil das Spiel nicht
anzeigt als retzbar, komm wir gehen hinten aufs Hochhaus, Hochhaus selbst, ja aber das
muss jetzt mal sein, hinten rauf aufs Hochhaus easy, also wer das noch nicht kennt, wer das
noch nicht kennt, man kann hinten so ne Zipp-Line rauf, also man kann hier die Treppe laufen
aber das ist mega sackig, du kannst den Fahrstuhl nehmen bis zu ner gewissen Höhe oder du gehst
hinten hin mit dieser Zipp-Line und machst so und stellst dich rauf und dann hoffst du
dass oben dich nicht 5 Leute abcampen, gibt innen auch, es gibt ne Zipp-Line oder ist
das einer, ok wir gehen wieder, wir gehen wieder, was wie, an was bin ich jetzt gestorben,
ich hing am Fallschirm, man weiß nicht so genau, Corona ja, oh ne sorry Leute ich hab
es nicht gecheckt mit dem retz, ja wahrscheinlich ja Corona, hat ja auch ein bisschen gedauert,
aber man kann hier auch, oh oh, die bashen mich sobald ich hoch komm, das ist keine so
gute Idee, da oben stehen 50 Gegner glaub ich gleich, nein, keine Chance, was willst
du machen, zwar richtig nice geowned die Typen aber was willst du machen, 37 jähriger Boomer
owned junge Schwitzer, das muss ich als Videotitel machen, einfach nur aus Spaß, just for fun,
soll ich, soll ich schreiben 37 jähriger Boomer owned junge Tryhards oder soll ich,
soll ich schreiben 37 jähriger Boomer owned Schwitzer, ich glaub Schwitzer versteht man
im deutschsprachigen Bereich besser, ich hab gestern, ich hab gestern nen Cutter kontaktiert,
der hat mich schon mal vor ner Weile angeschrieben und ich hab ihn gefragt, ob er mir nicht so
nen Highlight-Schnitt machen kann, Schwitzer, Schwitzer ist besser ne, ich seh, by the way
ich seh nix ne, hier ist ein Gegner bei uns drinnen, was 37 jähriger Boomer, Hemi, was
ist für ein Ding, das Wort sagt mir nix, dafür bin ich zu 37 jähriger Boomer, einfach Tryhards
Schwitzer, sehr gute Idee, sehr gute Idee, einfach nur, das muss ich mir kurz aufschreiben,
das ist ein super Titel, 37 jähriger Boomer, 37 jähriger Boomer bashed Tryhard Schwitzer,
sehr gut, find ich top, notes taken, sag mal da oben drauf ist doch, uuuh, der Dude ist
doch hier oben oder, na klar, deshalb verlieren wir das grad schon wieder, das hast du dir
so gedacht, Kollege, das hast du dir so gedacht, guck mal, was ne Range man, was ne Range,
Kek weh, da unten war er oder, oder war das meiner, er ist von meiner, was ne Range, das
Ding ist ja, guck mal, wie soll denn das funktionieren, was ist da für ein Akku drinnen, so mit nem
1200mAh Akku kommste da nicht aus für das Ding, unbalanced as fuck, ja, ist so, zum
iPhone Akku, das wird nix, nein, hier sind schon wieder so viele,
ok, ich hab's versucht Leute, ich hab's versucht, also mehr, mehr Verwirrungsgestellte kann
ich nicht machen, da sind mindestens 3A Batterien drin, na ich glaube, ich glaube das ist eher,
eher 18540 oder wie heißen die Dinger, wie für die E-Zikaretten, ich rauch by the way
nicht, die dicken, sehr gut, der Hook, 1856, ja, aufm Dach geht's ab, hallo, Crabble Hook,
komm raus, please, meine Güte, da ist hier die ganze Armee,
wie sie die ganze Armee mit ihren Helis am Start hat, die haben keine mehr, deswegen,
deswegen muss man aus Afghanistan abziehen, keine Ahnung, hier ist nix mehr, die haben
nix mehr, die sind grad alle hier, die sind alle hier, nirgendswo anders,
richtig viel los hier, aber wir haben's Leute, das war ein cooles Play,
du hörst ihn nicht, den Heli, du hörst ihn nicht, du hörst ihn einfach nicht, mit der
letzten Kugel, ja, aber du hörst ihn einfach nicht, wie viele Leute, das ist das Problem
bei 64 vs 64, du gewinnst einfach keine Fights und dann ist gewonnen, sondern das ist unendlich
Gegner, weiter geht's, eigentlich, guckt euch das mal an, das sind die einzigen drei
einsatzfähigen Hubschrauber, die die Bundeswehr hat, Reste sehr kaputt, ich blicke nicht mehr
durch Leute, ich blicke legit, ich blicke legit nicht mehr durch, es ist mir zu viel
gerade, Shit, jetzt hab ich verraten, Shit, da war noch einer, Mann, für die Aussage
die Bundeswehr kannst du gemäß NetzDG gesperrt werden, was, warum das denn, man kann mittlerweile
gegen alle gesperrt werden, ich retz dich, was war nochmal Speichern bei Shadowplay,
ich hab ihn nicht gesehen, ich hab ihn nicht gesehen, der kommt aus dem Boden gefahren,
warum steht der Name Doppelda, dass man sich geiler fühlt als man ist, vermute ich, ein
nicer retz, easy win, ey Maxi, funktioniert denn Rush jetzt bei Orbital, gar nicht, gar
nicht, ich bin mir nicht mal sicher, ob's Rush überhaupt geben wird, was mich persönlich
sehr enttäuschen würde, ich muss grad nochmal was anderes an Sound machen, nein, mein ich
bin nicht, wo ist es denn, ah, tss, du du du, du du, du du, du du, ist es nicht schön,
ist es nicht nice, das ist die Bad Company 1 Version, ja, und das ist, das ist das Bad
Company 1 Intro, Jack, hier, pass auf, jetzt kommt das Battlefield Theme, beste, Achtung,
beste Version finde ich, ne, das ist beste, beste Version, exquisite, oh, weiter geht's,
wo sind wir hier, also eins, einen Platz haben wir im Squad noch, ne, Glück haben, Glück
haben kann ich gleich an die Rakete, passt, come on, chat, über was streitet ihr euch
schon wieder, ob man was sagen darf auf Twitch oder nicht, hab ich Monkart-Post, was, was
genau ist mit diesem Heli da los, sieht bisschen kaputt aus, der Gude, man kann Anti-Alasing
wieder nicht ausmachen, na Gott sei Dank, ich stelle mir mal vor, also, na okay, ähm,
Gott sei Dank ist es an, das flimmert schon genug, gehen wir hier mal rauf, Zack, und
das hier, Zack, Zack, Zack, Zack, beste und Hopp, ich finde ja immer noch, dass Bad Company
den besten Soundtrack hatte, und die Main-Themes aus dem Alten, okay, aber seit Battlefield
3 machen die sonst nur, so, Battlefield Theme fertig, sollte ich verkaufen an EA, der Typ
auf dem Dach, ist hier einer auf dem Dach, ist hier einer auf dem Dach, es hat die Kamera
so krass gecheckt, dass ich nicht gecheckt hab, jetzt krieg ich den Kill geklaut, alles
weg, okay, war hier hinten nicht ein Auto, bleibst du da, bleibst du da, bleib hier, da
geht's by the way nicht lang, Kollege, das war die falsche Richtung, ich wollte es dir
schon mal sagen, also, wollen wir jetzt Hochhaus, Leute, ihr geht schon in die richtige Richtung,
perfekt, wir wollen Hochhaus, von hinten reinfahren in das Hochhaus wieder, richtig
schön durch die Hintertür, im Seil, und dann alles bashen oben, Supply Drop Mechanic,
ja ja, die geht halt nicht, die ist halt broken, okay, stirbt nicht, was zum Teufel ist denn
da los, da kommt was hoch, da kommt was hoch, oh, GG, hast du schön gebashed, ich glaube
nicht, dass der mich gerätst kriegt, oh, die bashen dich, Alter, wenn du mich rätst,
nett, oh, nice, Deckungsstelle, hat der gerade was Monkathos-mäßiges gesagt, der Soldat,
das hat sich sehr Monkathos angehört, was der gerade gesagt hat, sehr Monkathos, aber
sitzen die eben aus der Map, komm wir gehen rauf, Hallo, ich bin gerade einfach runter
gefallen, ohne dass was war, am besten ist immer noch Battlefield 3, wenn die Soldaten
da beschossen werden, I get fucked up in the ass over here, das ist auch Toss, das darfst
du auch nicht sagen, oh, oh, oh, oh, schlechte Idee, ganz, ganz, ganz schlechte Idee, Null
Kills, Kegweight, RIP, RIP, aber ist ja noch Rundenanfang, schnell, schnell rein hier,
schnell rein hier, ja Hochhaus ist immer ein bisschen Selbstmord, lebt er noch, wir
machen jetzt einfach, pass auf, da nicht, da nicht, ok, ich muss mal was killen jetzt,
ich habe noch keinen Gegner gefunden in der Runde, Yolo, ne hier ist nix, wir haben alles,
wir haben die ganze Map gecaptured, außer, den holen wir jetzt, du machst das da hinten,
ne jetzt ist er verreckt oder, easy, oh, da ist ein Auto, oh, oh, das ist ein LRV, das
ist kein normales Auto, das ist ein LRV, seit wann beschädigen Granaten denn LRVs, das ist
aber unrealistisch, das Spiel kaufe ich mir sicher nicht, ich spiele nur realistische
Spiele, Fortnite zum Beispiel, G-Baded, Massive G-Bade,
ernsthaft, seriously, ok, ne, ich kann nicht noch mal, ich kann nicht aufs Haus, guck mal
die Leute liegen da hinten schon am Aufgang vom Haus und verrecken, du spielst in Search
of the Sinstorm, das ist ja tatsächlich sogar relativ realistisch, ne, he, oh guck mal da
ist was, der will gebashed werden, alter ich sehe nichts wegen meinem Red Dot, der Red Dot
ist nicht red genug, ist der im Fahrstuhl, der ist im Fahrstuhl, come on, lass mich rein,
auf, ich will in den Fahrstuhl, Fahrstuhl, jawoll, nein, nein, ja, ja, ja, ja, exzellent,
auf gehts, klar kann man Shooter auf der Konsole spielen, kein Problem, ah jetzt gehts auch,
ok, das ist ne schlechte Idee, was ich jetzt hier mache, glaub ich,
jetzt gehts, nein, fuck man, die Muni verlehr, Pepehands, Pepehands und jetzt wird er auch
wiederbelebt, sprinte mal gegen die Fahrstuhltüre beim hoch oder runterfahren, du wirst dich
kaputtlachen, man kann durchrennen, das weiß ich, oder meinst du was anderes, man kann
durchrennen, wie der falsche immer Locations verrät, ja das ist ein bisschen undurchdacht,
oh, oh, oh, pass mal auf, 3Hat Mode, äh nein, nächster Versuch, nächster 3Hat Versuch,
nope, nope, ich wollt eigentlich, wenn ich schon mit dem Grappling Hook nicht schaffe,
ich wollt eigentlich versuchen hintenrum rauf, aber ja, das Game dachte sich nope, da fliegen
schon die Leichen runter, fuck, ok, wir müssen direkt hier hochgrappeln, 3Hat Move, naja,
Oh ich kann nicht mehr aimen was zum teufel das war ja mega das war fast schon commander
eben gerade auch ich werde gerätzt nein nein es geht ja kann gar nix
ist ja schon spät ja gleich bettke gleich ist bettke in zehn minuten da lohnt sich nicht
mal anzustrengen kommt aber die runde die runde geht noch was
gibt mal auf ok ich glaube das naja guck mal hier die stellsten hier um unsere leute
oder wir laufen jetzt sind wir walkers walker texas ranger den kenne ich noch gar nicht hier
wusste ich gar nicht dass es die gibt pass mal auf big brain ich kriege ich
was auch jetzt kommt von oben war keine das war eine ziemliche low iq aktionen man darf
sich hier gibt so viele man hier gibt so viele du darfst nicht einfach nicht mit einzelnen
gegnern aufhalten das ist pp gottheim alter ich will raus lass lass mich raus man ich will
raus ich darf übrigens gerade nicht nach unten gucken ich darf meine maus nicht bewegen
das ist brocken konsolen aim wee wee steuerung leute wee controls wee controls steifer nacken
ja mein gott die runde mit der rei geschissen mann guckt euch das mal an sechsechs das ist
die schlechteste runde seit beta beginn lukaku cry more geht gut ok soll ich sollte wirklich
aufhören zu sprain ich gehe da nicht noch mal oder kommen ein nein ich gehe nicht noch
mal hoch vergesst es ich gehe nicht hoch ich habe schiss im better ja ich muss am anfang
des streams reiz ich mich immer voll zusammen so mit somit kontrolliert aim kontrolliert
zielen und aber jetzt so nach ab einer gewissen zeit ist einfach sprain pray angesagt guck
hier ist auch so ein ding warum steht ein auto drin kommt man hier jetzt raus ach nee das
ist da waren wir eben schon sind die du zimmer noch da pass auf ich werde abgeeimt da oben
guck mal guck mal seht ihr es dumm richtig dumm wollte eigentlich den medipack legen
aber es funktioniert gerade nicht das haben sie hier haben sie sich line of sight haben
sie sich gedanken gemacht okie haben sie sich line of sight gedanken gemacht die dudes kann
man hier sowas machen wartet mal wartet mal big brain time alter ich habe kein glück
heute krieg einfach nur auf den sack in der runde ist einfach vorbei ich hätte ich hätte
ich hätte einfach um die ecke kommen können aber nein gibt es nicht ok wo gehen wir jetzt
hin auf das dach habe ich kein bock mehr hier unten c1 hallo c please was das für ein gestörner
beim abkratzen wieder von allen seiten das serious max carried mich jetzt easy carry kann
man eigentlich während dem slide das medipack werfen ich glaube ja glaube ja die cap schon
was halt cool wäre wenn ich jetzt ein auto droppen könnte was halt nicht geht 16 11
8 das ist schlechteste runde seit beta beginnt aber ich schiebe es einfach drauf gleich ist
bettgetheim mein boomer kopf kann das einfach nicht so lang aber heute waren richtig coole
plays dabei ich muss unbedingt mir irgendwie mal so ein highlight schneiden lassen es waren
wirklich neiße sachen bei schon spät bettge ja sag ich doch mag die map nicht sagt der
chat ja ich ich auch nicht aber was bleibt dir anderes übrig da machst du nix hier
nichts anderes übrig mich trägt auch wieder wie es da laufen irgendwas zuckt mensch überall
es sind einfach zu viele spieler in dem leute ich sag euch in dem 32 versus 32 hättest du
den letzten hier wahrscheinlich nicht mehr gehabt sind einfach es ist einfach zu viel
los es ist nix los oder es ist zu viel los und da ist da ist hier huge sport massive sport
ok gehen wir rauf dem los ist mit dem los wir machen jetzt einfach reverse ja komm
wir nicht hin man du wirst dir wirklich von 100 seiten abgeähmt es geht einfach nicht
es ist so viele so brutals viele klar ja ich weiß ich bin auf bettgetheim über bettgetzeit
leute der hat man bestimmt gesehen aber die verwandeln nicht jetzt hier nochmal aber die
gegner Leute was witzig ist jetzt wo wir so schlecht sind und das team heftig rein wenigstens
das wenigstens das da vorne stehen übrigens drei stück alter wo du hin rennst ist was
jetzt ist der schlaf jetzt ist der schlafrhythmus kaputt ja jetzt vorbei jetzt ist jetzt ist
vorbei also zwei minuten drüber ist ist gelaufen rib rib schlafrhythmus würde gerne hier hoch
rib schlafrhythmus ich ok ist so ich bin wirklich über meine bettgetheim heute rüber geht
gerade nichts mehr hast schon mal colorblind probiert ich glaube nicht dass das was ändert
so ich denke da kommt ihr steht das war dumm
ich habe gedacht ich komme noch mal weg aber nope
kommen kommen in der besten beta andere modis und maps nein es gibt nur ein modus keine
5 waffen eine map das ist äußerst minimalistisch sehr sehr minimalistisch wisst ihr ich bin
ich bin eigentlich sobald schlecht läuft bin ich so der richtige stats kucker so es läuft
immer noch schlecht läuft der arzt läuft immer noch schlecht richtig pepega vielleicht
jetzt auf a ich meine wir haben noch ein bisschen zeit wir haben noch ein bisschen zeit was
mit dem los ernsthaft wir haben uns einfach gerade gegenseitig gebashed wir haben uns
gegenseitig in den kopf geschossen sind hier leute am start noch pass ich will die andere
richtung
auch mal mit dem pack ist weg gerade es ist wieder anstrengend sehr anstrengend übrigens
was auch ein bisschen fail ist du hast überhaupt keine respawn zeit respawn time du bist quasi
du bist quasi dead und gleich wieder da also ein bisschen respawn zeit wäre echt nicht
verkehr laufen laufen laufen laufen das ist ein century gun oder ok
ok nexta wo sind sie hier versuchst du dich zu retzen max
es dauert viel zu lang bis dahin habe ich zwei neue soldaten ausgebildet
bis der hier aufgestanden ist wenn ich am rett etwas sehen würde da könne ich auch
treffen die ist ja nix null ok ist jetzt alles tot vermute mal hier ist irgendwo ist hier
noch was sonst wäre sonst wäre tut ihr nicht gestorben grad
ich bin erst einmal durchgefahren glaubt er benutzt keiner sehr getunnelt weil ihn keiner
benutzt
ist verlängert worden nein morgen 9 uhr ist schluss morgen 9 uhr ist schluss
so leute wollen wir noch eine runde spielen ich mein es ist samstag abend eine also eine
würde ich wahrscheinlich serius max ist raus ne dann hör ich auch auf wenn du auch raus
bist hör ich auf ich wollte noch den colorblind mode sehen ok kann ich anmachen
jeder erzählt dass sie heute um 21 zu ende ist weil die leute pepega sind es ist 9 uhr
c est 9 uhr am p.m. was ist vormittag es ist vormittag auf jeden fall am ist vormittag
ja um eine runde spiel ich noch easy aber noch irgendjemand selbst und es gibt leute
wusste gar nicht mal dass sie noch vorhanden sind kann ich den join join den jetzt einfach
mal random leuten gejohnt aus der freundesliste ne ne ne gegen nicht gegen nicht versteht
es manchmal nicht so genau so da ist der flieger da fliegen wir mit der osprey gunner da kann
man in der zwischenzeit schon mal sein gelöns hier ausrüsten und sobald jetzt müssen wir
eine map auf machen ich sehe wo ich bin o ne hochhaus pepega hochhaus pepega kram da
habe ich ja gar keinen bock drauf hochhaus ist richtig pepega stellt immer die hochhaus
pepegas haben wir eingenommen ja dann wollen wir mal hier ne dann colorblind mode ja sag
wo geht denn das options display das da wo ihr müsst mir sagen wo der colorblind mode
ist hat danger i can ah accessibility colorblind mode ok wir haben jetzt deuterranopia ok gut
wie wir haben das überlebt wir liegen immer noch hier das sieht für mich genau gleich
aus na doch das rot oben ist ein bisschen anders das rot oben ist ein bisschen anders
oder oder bild ich mir das ein ja guck mal die flaggen und so die farben sind ein bisschen
anders ok was machen wir als nächstes options tri tritanopia war die wirklich anders aus
es ändert sich bei neuem game ok dann stelle ich jetzt wieder zurück options of
eck hier sind noch mehr
jetzt werden sie geschreckt ich muss mich auch kurz in die ecke campen ich höre nämlich
rechts was nein zu viel auf einmal zu viel auf einmal zu viel auf einmal man hört aber
also ich hab gedacht ich hab was gehört aber da kam daraus komplett controller geht übrigens
auch nicht am pc ich hab doch gestern beim ich hab doch gestern zwei sekunden beim krieger
reingeguckt und der hat mit konter da hat mir der chat gesagt er würde mit controller
am pc spielen ok was auch immer absolut gegoogelt ist echt ein bug der oft auftritt ok
hätte eigentlich hätte eigentlich gedacht das geht hier müssen wir jetzt hin beschen
alle beschen beschen alle beschen beschen beschen beschen beschen alle beschen
oder wir haben zu zu kurz gebäscht wir müssen kurz wir müssen kurz unser grappling hook
ich habe es probiert ich habe es probiert wir haben uns beide gleich anguckt die begleitet
mich jetzt alter du spazierst das wer die weg mich hier wer die weg mich hier anzeige
ist raus aber sowas von monka tos richtiger tos ok predict ich predikte mal ein paar granaten
da bin mir nicht so sicher ob die irgendwas hinten ok ok man muss an das gilt für alle
shooter man muss an unerwarteten stellen sein wenn man an unerwarteten stellen ist dann
und man ok ist nichts mehr das ich retz dich
nein nein nein du siehst ihn aus glaube ich glaube es hat von hinten noch einer drauf
geschossen ich glaube es hat von hinten noch einer drauf geschossen ich dachte zwar ich
den kompletten five head outplayed move oh komm mal kaum kaum kaum oh shit ich wollte
gerade sagen kaum teamplay revanchiert das sich und retzt auch hätte ja klappen können
so wo gehen wir denn jetzt hin a ist safe b ist auch relativ safe unten ist halt voll
was fack ja ich hab gesagt ich mach noch ne runde eine runde mach ich noch ok vergiss
es ok wir müssen jetzt wir müssen jetzt ran stülsen an die wir gehen hier runter wir
gehen hier runter und wir stellten uns hinter die also so dass die uns nicht abschießen
können mensch bettel fielt fack man genau da wo der typ ist wollte ich ein schön das
auto eben ist auch noch was ich seh nix ich seh nix seh nix rauch rauch rauch die sind
so viele sind so viele spieler hier ist einfach überall so viel los monka es ich hab den
sicherlich auch ich hätte ihn besser treffen können aber da war noch vier stück drum
herum was willst du denn machen die nukes waren auto leute sind im game viel schlimmer
es gibt einfach keine autos zum fahren heli gehe weg
wo sind die hier
und die achtung leute jetzt wird reingefahren von hinten in der ask schudet man die amens
ab die wussten es einfach die amens ab du kannst hier keine place gerade machen nicht
nicht möglich und hier oben ist wieder 50 50 piloten helis monka es vergisst es doch
einfach vergisst es leute das war so drauf das war so drauf so next next next next
bastion alter bastion ist so viel wir gehen jetzt mal d ok flanken flanken flanken
und jetzt ist alles tot
richtig pepega richtig pepega
ok die hüpfen immer noch am haus unten rum
monka da ist noch einer immer gut
muss mich immer rüber stellen die fallschirme du weißt einfach schon wo ihr was geht
oder ist unten vielleicht kommt da hoch vielleicht kommt da hoch
ja oder auch nicht gerade im reload shit normalerweise in battlefield 3 hätte jetzt einfach mal kurz
wissen jetzt hier gibt es kein team hat was von spiderfield ja es ist so wir spawnen jetzt
gleich 50.000 leute immer so oder sie haben keinen bock hier zu sparen kann auch sein
wenn sie hier spawnen dann spawnen sie eigentlich immer dahinten aber schön spawn campen ja
jetzt gesporned next dein lieblingsbattlefield ist immer noch battlefield 3 ja meins auch
hinter mir guck jetzt kommen sie hergelaufen und die wissen dass ich da bin deswegen muss
ich mich jetzt ganz schnell verpissen habe den spawn gesehen der ist direkt in mir gesporned
im bobs drinnen gatschi
immer hinter einem gibt dem spieler erstmal eine chance in allen erinnerungsschwellen
bringt auch nix das hat in dem fall wenig mit erinnerungsschwellen zu tun das spiel
ist halt verbackt und bis jetzt ist battlefield 3 auch mein lieblingsbattlefield mal gucken
wie das hier wird aber nach allem dem was sich abzeichnet wird es noch eine ganze weile
dauern bis das spielbar ist ich lasse mich da ich lasse mich da sehr gerne eines besseren
belehren und es kommt im perfekten zustand raus ich wäre der letzte der sich darüber
beschwert ich würde mich freuen aber es wird nicht so sein wenn es allein schon die visibility
der gegner guckt euch an irgendwo hier ist er ich habe keine ahnung wo ach da ach da
ok jetzt alles dauernd und jetzt kommt walking simulator zu f press f ja übers es ist wirklich
du siehst gegner einfach nur ultra schlecht ok das wird meine letzte runde der beta weil
gleich muss ich bettige gleich muss ich bettige und morgen früh ist dann vorbei morgen früh
wieder aufwachen stream wie immer ok jetzt müssen wir ein bisschen ausbleiben weil ich
glaube jetzt spawnen sie hier rein da sind sie schon
die sporn halt außerhalb von den points während du schon drinnen bist also die die umzingeln
dich quasi automatisch durch spornknopf drücken hier ist jetzt aber anscheinend weg hier ist
anscheinend nichts mehr hier sie dann ich weiter walking simulator machen
conquest mochtest du ihn noch nie gesagt hat ich war auch jahrelang rush fan aber ich habe
in letzter zeit angefangen vermehrt conquest zu spielen und battlefield 3 macht conquest
auch mega bock also auf den einschlägigen map irgendwie großartiger jet fan auf caspian
border werde ich nie werden aber kann er noch werden wir müssen ein bisschen weiter laufen
hier ok walking simulator beendet wahrscheinlich sterben simulator sterben simulator activated
nicht hängen bleiben please ok dach range
walkers range jetzt jetzt wackelts mir ein bisschen viel
abgehängt vor mir reicht es für heute aber echt eine güne
bettgetime das shaking das habe ich ausgeschaltet das shaking ist aus das interessiert das das
interessiert das aber nicht alles klar ich habe das shaking ausgeschaltet komm mal hier
wir jetzt ein ad ad spam macht ad ad spam da siehst du da siehst du gleich wir haben
jetzt die tryhard leute erwischt nein würdest du auch so machen oh was haben wir hier feindliche
bietstelzen alter das schickt das schickt es fack
der lebt noch beide bei dahinten
der schenkt den jetzt den gegnern
sagt immer da sein wo man nicht erwartet wird
wir haben es oder da bin ich mir jetzt nicht sicher wo es hier abgeht sind die da unten
drinnen ok jawoll auf gehts böschen man muss hier hinten direkt ne anflug ist zu ppega
das wird nix und jetzt kommt die vis-visibility königsklasse hier
nein kommt gleich von rechts die vis-visibility königsklasse
kommt kommt hier noch jemand also ich meine kommt hier noch ein team
von links wieder
ja auf raus der macht die tür zu habt ihr es gesehen
ich
ich höre doch hier was
ich brauche muni ok wenn wir glück haben können wir jetzt vor
wir haben klug auf auf auf ok easy nein nicht da oben drauf mensch
jawoll perfekt exzellent
easy spot easy spot easy life easy spot easy spot
was du machen was du machen
normalerweise würden stehen jetzt ab eben ob er gerätzt wird aber in dem spiel wird
keiner gerätzt ok easy win
battlefield 1 und 5 liefen zu release ziemlich gut
battlefield 5 und 5 lief in der beta schon ziemlich gut
nahezu perfekt eigentlich hierfür jetzt es reicht für heute leute es ist genug
es ist genug
anstrengende sache ja das war es 37er best tryhard schwitzer
das brauche ich unbedingt der beste titel überhaupt
ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen ich werde jetzt ich werde es gleich aufgehen
morgen früh bin ich wieder am start um acht ne quatsch was laberisch um acht um halb zehn
oder so halb zehn zehn um acht meine güte um acht ist klar
und dann machen wir die übliche übliche aufwach stream beta ist ja dann quasi vorbei
den hosten wir den solution oder der spielt fifa ich mag fifa nicht
mag jemand follow ich fifa ich nicht ein fifa
seltsam dass die beta nicht bis sonntag läuft
naja sie läuft ja bis sonntag abend nur nicht unsere nur nicht unsere zeitzone
tja wirklich wenig hosten kann gerade
ich hause ja am liebsten leute die mich selbst follow und die nicht so viele zuschauer haben
weiß nicht ich geh jetzt ins bett leute wir sehen uns morgen früh
bis denn wupp bettke alles klar machts gut cu